[Musique]
Jacques de la Rosière bonjour bonjour
top benoî bonjour Jacques de la Rosière
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succeintement aujourd'hui on va parler
finances géopolitique géostratégie
Jacques de la Rosière ch présentez-vous
succès je suis ravi d'être là parce que
votre émission va me permettre de parler
de choses auxquelles je crois et de
parler
librement alors c'est un privilège
énorme vous voulez que je me présente
s'il vous plaît oui alors je suis
Jacques de la Rosière j'ai 94 ans j'ai
eu une carrière très riche et eu
beaucoup de chance dans les années 70
j'étais à la direction du Trésor que
j'ai dirigé ensuite de
78 à 87 c'est-à-dire pendant 9 ans j'ai
été le directeur général du Fond
Monétaire International à Washington
ensuite j'ai été gouverneur de la Banque
de France de 87 à 93 pendant 5 ans et
ensuite je suis devenu le président de
la banque pour la reconstruction et le
développement qu'on appelle la berde qui
était une banque pour le renouveau des
pays de l'Est qui venaient de retrouver
leur liberté croyeit-on et et donc je
l'ai présidé jusqu'en
97 98 et après je suis rentré dans les
rangs je suis devenu conseiller auprès
de BNP Paribas et je suis maintenant un
auteur qui aime écrire alors voilà en
gros ma ma carrière Tom Benoît bonjour
alors voilà Tom Benoît je suis directeur
actuellement de la rédaction de
géostratégie magazine qui est donc un
trimestriel distribué en kiosque partout
en France qui est un média qui a la
particularité d'être très libre puisque
je suis propriétaire de la rédaction et
mon associé Robert Laffond est
propriétaire de la diffusion de ce
magazine donc nous sommes deux éditeurs
pour ce magazine et seulement deux
éditeurs il y a pas d'actionnaire
extérieur en dehors de de Robert Laffond
et de moi-même j'ai écrit plusieurs
ouvrages notamment de philosophie j'ai
étudié la la philosophie dans mes jeunes
années j'ai étudié l'immobilier
également j'ai un BTS immobilier j'ai
enseigné dans une école privée
d'immobilier le droit immobilier et je
produis également des émissions qui
s'appellent philoscopie sur TV5 Monde et
pour le dernier numéro Jacques de la
Rosière était invité de l'émission phos
magnifique on a décidé de vous faire
venir tous les deux un pour combler le
fossé intergénérationnel parce que 94
ans et et Tom 28 ans né en
1995 c'est important qu'on parle parce
que à l'heure actuelle on voudrait avoir
votre éclairage Jacques concernant les
banques centrales la politique monétaire
les les comptes de fait qu'on peut nous
raconter vous avez la parole alors je
vous remercie beaucoup parce que c'est
un sujet que j'ai beaucoup étudié celui
de la politique des banques centrales et
je suis arrivé à conclusions assez
critiques sur ce qui s'est passé les
banques centrales depuis à peu près 25
ans émettent beaucoup de monnaie ce
qu'on appelle la Fiat monnaie
c'est-à-dire la monnaie qu'on crée avec
un clic sur son son ordinateur la
planche habillée c'est c'est la monnaie
qu'on crée et ils ont été très
accommodant comme on dit polent pour ne
pas dire laxiste dans la gestion de
cette politique monétaire et quand vous
regardez les chiffres ce qu'il faut
faire vous voyez que pendant 20 ans 22
ans les taux d'intérêt directeurs
c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont émis par la
Banque centrale ceux qui sont de la
Banque centrale c'est tau d'intérêt en
terme réel qu' son les seuls qui
comptent ils sont défalqués si vous
voulez de l'inflation les taux d'intérêt
réel ont été à zéro voire pendant
plusieurs années négatifs ça c'est la
première caractéristique c'est très
étrange parce que ça veut dire que si
vous êtes un
épargnant on vous sert zéro voire un peu
de négatif sur votre épargne or vous le
savez l'épargne c'est ce qui finance 90
% de l'investissement d'un pays donc
c'est à première vue un peu étrange de
servir un intérêt zéro voire négatif
c'est-à-dire une taxe pour celui qui
apporte de l'argent à l'économie de
façon à ce qu'elle puisse investir ça
c'est la première caractéristique la
deuxième caractéristique c'est que l'on
a fabriqué de la monnaie toujours plus
que le taux de croissance de l'économie
réelle il y a 20 ans c'est si vieux il y
a 20 ans il y avait un parallélisme
entre la création de financement et la
croissance économique autrement dit
quand la croissance économique en terme
réel était 3 % l'augmentation des
financements était autour de 3 % et la
consommation énergétique suivait de même
c'était un parallélisme ce parallélisme
n'existe plus depuis 20 ans depuis 20
ans c'est la monnaie la le financement
qui dépasse la croissance économique
réelle alors on le sait pas
ça mais moi je vous dis que c'est une
des plus grandes innovations
délétair de notre temps c'est que on
considère normal que pour créer un de
richesse il faut maintenant TR ou qu ou
C de financement alors ça c'est la
deuxème chose c'est donc la
accommodation la facilité de la
politique monétaire qui a toujours
dépassé ce qu'il fallait financer
c'est-à-dire la réalité du
PIB la 4è chose c'est que d'habitude bon
c'est ce qu'on m'avait appris quand j'ai
pris les rennes de la Banque de France
d'habitude qu'est-ce qu'on regarde quand
on est un banquier central la première
chose qu'on regarde c'est l'évolution du
crédit à l'économie et au par
particulier pourquoi parce que c'est par
le crédit que l'on obtient des banques
que l'on fait des choses que l'on
investit que l'on
consomme alors ce qui est intéressant
c'est que dans l'optique traditionnelle
des banques centrales on faisait
attention à ce que l'évolution du crédit
à l'économie et au particulier ne soit
pas trop importante parce que si elle
est trop
importante par rapport au besoins
financés le risque c'est l'inflation et
ce qui m'étonne et me désole dans la
situation actuelle c'est que depuis 20
ans le
crédit a bondi le crédit a explosé il a
triplé doublé selon les les modes de
calcul et l'économie que l'on finançait
ainsi est resté très molle de croissance
très faible de l'ordre de 1 à 2 %. donc
dans un cas vous avez une croissance
réelle qui est très faible et une
croissance du financement qui est
explosive et ce qui me m'étonne dans la
situation actuelle c'est que l'évolution
du crédit qui a été littéralement folle
n'a pas inquiété les banquiers centraux
autrefois c'était
une lampe clignotante très importante
sur le tableau de bord on regarder le
crédit aujourd'hui on garde pas le
crédit je peux vous couper Jacques je
peux vous couper je vous coupe là là oui
pourquoi les banquiers centraux ont
laissé faire l'évolution galopante cette
cavalerie de crédit c'est la bonne
question pourquoi les banques centrales
ont laissé fait à mon avis il y a une
foule de raisons la première raison
c'est que on a voulu être entre
guillemets
kénésien c'est-à-dire que Kees a trouvé
l'idée géniale après la dépression de
1929 que en accélérant en incitant à une
augmentation de ce qu' l'on appelle la
demande interne la demande des ménages
et des entreprises en l'incitant un peu
avec de la politique monétaire à taux
plus faible on arrivait à développer
l'économie parce que ce qu'on avait pas
pu financer sans abondance de crédit on
pouvait le faire avec l'abondance du
crédit ce principe
kénésien est toujours valable il y a un
multiplicateur du crédit quand on fait
plus de crédit on a plus de demandes et
quand on a plus de demandes on a une
économie qui est plus plus allante
mais le
problème c'est que le multiplicateur
kainésien n'est pas sans limite si votre
situation d'endettement publ devient
très lourde très
inconséquente
ingérable appuyer sur
l'accélérateur de la demande interne
comme le faisait ke n'a plus de sens
parce que vous n'avez pas la marge qui
vous permet je dirais fiscalement
budgétairement d'honorer votre
supplément de croissance parce que avec
cette faible marge budgétaire que
qu'entraîne les grands déficits que nous
connaissons avec ça qu'est-ce qui se
passe il se passe que le crédit est plus
cher et que quand vous empruntez c'est
de plus en plus cher et aujourd'hui on a
calculé cette marge qui ienne que l'on
peut utiliser pour accélérer l'économie
et on s'aperçoit que les phénomènes de
frein internes que je décris qui sont
ceux des taux d'intérêt qui monent de la
difficulté physique
d'emprunter comment dirait gêne le
multiplicateur de crédit donc on a fait
du kénésianisme mais on ne s'est pas
rendu compte que
l'environnement budgétaire et fiscal de
ce
kénésanisme était périmé ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que les banquiers centraux ont voulu
être populaires
alors si vous dites à quelqu'un qui est
un banquier central tu vas pouvoir créer
de la monnaie de manière illimitée
deuxièmement tu vas la créer avec un
taux de d'intérêt une rémunération de
zéro et
qurièmement tu vas te désintéressé
totalement de l'État d'endettement de
l'économie si vous lui dites ça il croit
qu'il va être populaire sil fait ces
quatre choses et en effet il devient
populaire seulement en faisant ces
quatre choses il détériore d'une manière
terrible ce qu'on appelle le tissu
financier et ça on pourra y revenir dans
la suite de vos question mais c'est
c'est un point central alors ce sont ces
raisonsl le désir d'être fidèle à Kees
alors qu'on n'était pas fidèle à Kees
deuxièmement le désir de la popularité
et troisièmement le
manphicisme
sur l'état de crédit de l'économie sur
cette folie du crédit de l'économie ces
trois ou quatre éléments expliquent que
les banques centrales et fait ce que
j'ai expliquer c'est-à-dire un
financement exagéré par rapport à la
croissance réelle de l'économie prince
Jacques quelles vont être les
conséquences de ça bah les conséquences
elles sont très visible et et très
importante quand vous faites beaucoup de
crédit à l'économie vous créez
automatiquement une vulnérabilité c'est
que les gens qui sont juste investment
grade qui sont justes éligibles au
crédit ont du crédit facile il est à
zéro donc le banquier qui regarde le
profil financier de l'intéressé candidat
en pinteur est assez rassuré il dit
toute façon le service de sa dette ça va
être zéro donc il peut être un débiteur
de qualité moyenne il arrivera quand
même à me
rembourser
donc on on on laisse entrer dans le
domaine de l'élig ilité au crédit des
gens qui normalement si les taux
d'intérêt étaient positifs seraient
écartés du crédit alors eux ils sont pas
écartés mais dès que et on le voit
aujourd'hui il y a un renversement de
marché dès que les taux d'intérêt
remontent pour une raison ou pour une
autre ces emprunteurs là sont en grande
difficulté et quand ils sont en grande
difficulté ils périssent ils font
faillite et la multiplication des
faillites d'une catégorie importante de
débiteurs génère si vous voulez un effet
euh de détérioration de l'ensemble du
système financier les les débiteurs les
plus fragile périssent et vous avez ce
qu'on appelle une crise financière qui
commence par les débiteurs de mauvaise
qualité alors parce que quand un
débiteur de mauvaise qualité est là il
faut provisionner les crédits qui ne
sont plus
il sont plus opérables si vous voulez ce
qu'on appelle les non performing loans
alors les nonperforming LO augmentent il
faut le savoir dans la période actuelle
parce que on a facilité le crédit à des
gens qui étaient à la limite de du
crédit ça c'est la première conséquence
donc c'est la conséquence c'est la crise
financière qui est facilité
par la vulnérabilité des mauvais des
mauvais débiteurs la deuxième chose qui
est à mon avis plus importante c'est que
quand vous mettez des taux d'intérêt
zéro qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
dites à quelqu'un qui veut apporter son
argent soit à une entreprise qui veut
investir soit à l'état qui veut financer
son budget vous lui dites à ce à ce
candidat
prêteur je te remercie tu vas m'apporter
ton argent mais je te signale dès le
départ tu ne seras pas rémunéré et
peut-être tu seras d'ailleurs légèrement
taxé quand vous faites
ça vous ne croyez pas une seconde si
vous avez votre bon sens que vous allez
avoir une Corte de candidat à vous
prêter de l'argent qu'est-ce qui se
passe il se passe que les gens ne
prêtent plus leur argent les gens le
gardent
les épargnants les gens le gardent parce
que ils disent ils sont rationnels ils
disent si
j'investis ma liquidité mon épargne ce
que j'ai mis de côté si je l'investis
dans un projet intéressant un projet de
transformation énergétique projet qui va
durer 25 ans un projet qui est incertain
parce que je suis pas absolument sûr de
la qualité de la filière technologique
dans laquelle je m'engage mais j'y vais
quand même parce que j'ai le sens du
risque mais qu'on me dise ah oui mais au
bout de tes 25 ans tu auras zéro
peut-être même tu vas être légèrement
taxé qu'est-ce que vous faites quand
vous êtes rationnel et kavait très bien
décrit ben vous ne prêtez pas vous ne
prêtez pas vous gardez votre liquidité
vous pouvez la mettre sous votre matelas
sous forme de billet vous pouvez la
garder dans votre compte de caisse
d'épargne vous pouvez garnir votre
compte en banque mais toutes ces choses
sont des liquidités c'est du très très
court terme je peux mobiliser toutes les
formes que je viens de dire à tout
moment pour euh pour entrer dans dans la
consommation des liquidité exposée à
l'inflation mais
absolument absolument et ce que l'on a
vu mais on l'a vu avec retard comme euh
c'est le fil conducteur de tout ce que
je pense quand on a vu que
l'investissement
productif non pas était stabilisé mais
diminué c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire économique qu'on voit
l'investissement productif je mets pas
les les appartements là-dedans je mets
que le productif les machines les usines
les équipements et cetera tout ça ça
décline d'une manière significative
depuis que les taux d'intérêt sont
négatifs alors les gens qui nous
gouvernent dans les palais ministériels
disent non non mais c'est pas grave ça
euh c'est parce que il y a des
investissements euh
euh intangible qui prennent la relève
alors vous étudiez ça j'ai étudié cette
affit la part
d'augmentation des
investissements intangibles qui sont à
élément de l'économie actuelle et
surtout diton de l'économie future cette
partie là a légèrement augmenté mais son
augmentation est loin d'avoir compensé
la diminution générale des
investissements productif donc on a une
situation dans laquelle on croyait avoir
dit à l'économie chic l'argent c'est
zéro maintenant investissez et ben on n
pas eu ça on a eu un D investissement
curieux l'argent étant à zéro ça devit
être formidableinestir et ben non c'est
pas formidable parce que les gens
veulent une rémunération pour payer le
risque qu'ils prennent c'est double
risque le risque de
l'immobilisation de quelque chose qui
était mobile qui était utilisable à tout
moment et c'est le risque d'échec et ce
risque doit être payé alors ce risque
n'a pas été payé pourquoi parce que
c'est pas le le marché qui a été à 0 %.
c'est les banquiers centraux qui ont
décidé que l'argent taux directeur des
banques centrales serait à zéro en
termes réels et il faut réfléchir une
seconde pourquoi ils ont eu cette idée
curieuse à savoir
que quelqu'un qui voulait prêter à
l'état euh devait accepter d'être taxé
parce que il avait l'outrecudence de
prêter à l'état pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
sont arrivés à cette notionl en dehors
de du désir de popularité que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure ils l'ont fait
parce que ils ont cru sincèrement que de
l'argent à zéro c'était quelque chose
qui était bon pour l'investissement
productif et ils se sont trompés ils
n'auraient pas dû se tromper parce que
Kees tout stimulateur qu'il fut
tout agitateur de la demande privé qui
qu'il était par le déficit budgétaire
par des taux d'intérêt faible disait et
j'ai lu les passages dans l'économ dans
le livre de du Traité d'économie
générale de de Kees il disait faut faire
très attention avec les taux d'intérêt
il faut qu'il soit suffisamment bas pour
entraîner la machine économique mais il
faut pas qu'ils soit trop bas parce que
s'ils sont trop bas on a le phénomène
qu'il appelait larape à liquidité
c'est-à-dire que si vous ne rémunérez
plus du tout l'épargnon il reste liquide
et il ne va pas dans les projets d'où la
baisse de
l'investissement productif que nous
connaissons et qui est tragique parce
que on a besoin d'investissement on a
besoin d'investissement énergétique
écologique tout ce que vous voulez
on ne peut pas les faire alors une
fausse bonne idée ah chic on va avoir 20
ans de taux zéro est une mauvaise ce qui
a favorisé les investissements
immobiliers principalement d'ailleurs
parce que lorsque vous avez des taux zé
naturellement il y a des investissements
immobilier qui se font qui pluser il
faut le dire malgré tout dans un
milieu vous pouvez vous procurer de
l'immobilier c'est dire qu'aujourd'hui
le volume monétaire global représente si
on libelle en euros ou en dollar c'est à
peu près pareil 89 trillions donc
89000 milliards 89000 milliards de
dollars ou d'euros de monnaie en
circulation converti en baril de pétrole
ça fait combien B là il faudrait parler
en rouble puisque c'est une monnaie
d'énergie si vous voulez parler de
pétrole on peut en parler également
j'entendais ce que vous disez au départ
c'était très intéressant vous regardez
le cours du rouble depuis sa création et
le cours du pétrole il y a une étroite
corrélation entre le cours du rouble et
le cours du pétrole donc on pourrait
revenir sur ce sujet égal en terme de
PIB je parlais pas du rouble
spécifiquement je disais que la
croissance du PIB en général la
croissance énergétique de consommation
énergétique derrière suit alors oui moi
j'aime pas beaucoup parler en PIB parce
que notamment par rapport à la dette si
vous regardez en France on a 3000
milliards de dettes aujourd'hui ça fait
combien en baril de pétrole en baril de
pétrole gen là lib en euros j'aurais pas
3000 milliards de de dette en euros 111
% du PIB qui a un petit peu baissé par
rapport au PIB nominal mais il vaudrait
mieux regarder la dette sur ce sujet-là
par rapport aux recettes de l'État
plutôt que par rapport au PIB parce que
vous regardez la dette par rapport au
PIB mais le PIB ça ne représente pas
l'état l'État ne représente pas la
totalité du PIB les dépenses de l'État
aujourd'hui par rapport au PIB c'est 58
% voilà 58,5 à peu près c'est le plus
élevé hein par rapport à l'OCDE 42 % de
moyenne pour les pays de l'OCDE et en
Europe on n'est pas très loin également
entre 42 et 50 %. donc il serait
beaucoup plus logique aujourd'hui de
regarder la dette publique par rapport
aux recettes de l'État puisque l'État
était une affaire rentable si je puis
dire dans les années 70 jusqu'à en
1975 77 par là et à partir de 1975- 1977
l'État français est devenu déficitaire
avec une régularité sans faille donc
c'est sous cet angle là qu'il faut Abor
aborder l'endettement sans parler des
pays exportateurs on y reviendra
également qui achètent avec de
l'impression de monnaie que nous opérons
dans nos pays occidentaux
euh de de la datte occidentale
essentiellement ce qui se produit depuis
breton Woods depuis 1945 et ce qui
représente un système qui est peut-être
en train de sinon de s'effondrer mais de
de battre de l'aile mais par rapport à
l'inflation ce que je voulais dire
principalement sur le le tout ce que
soulignait Jacques et qui est très juste
c'est que par rapport aux années
70 que l'on prend régulièrement pour
référence parce qu'il y a eu un choc
pétrolier durant les années
70 la différence principale c'est que si
vous prenez la France en 1975 vous avez
un taux d'inflation assez élevée et vous
avez un immobilier qui monte également
un cours de l'immobilier qui est
asentionnel aujourd'hui vous avez une
inflation très élevée mais vous avez des
chutes des prix de l'immobilier qui ne
vont faire que s'ac croître durant les
mois et les années à venir c'est la
stagflation c'est ça c'est une situation
de stagflation j'avais évoqué ce sujet
avec Bruno Lemer sur TV5 Monde au mois
de mai dernier il a compris le
mot Bruno Lemire a déclaré en tout cas
je parlerai pas au nom de Bruno Lemire
que nous n'étions pas en situation de
stagflation qu'il avait pas compris le
mot selon moi nous sommes en situation
de stagflation mais lorsque vous êtes au
manette vous avez naturellement beaucoup
moins d'ésan que je nanis aujourd'hui
parce que je suis entre entrepreneur et
patron de presse et pas ministre je je
regretterai pas d'être ministre parce
que je suis profondément souverainiste
et républicain et que j'aimerais
beaucoup être au service de mon pays
mais j'aurais une parole probablement
beaucoup plus muselée si je l'étais
Jacques ou oui je voulais terminer avec
votre question sur les effets de cette
politique
accommodante je vous ai dit
que l'effet ton inérêt a
été en fait déjoué par la trappe à
liquidité de Kees je vous ai dit que
l'investissement avait été défavorisé
par le fait que quand on investissait à
long terme on était pénalisé et je
m'étais arrêté là la troisème chose que
j'observe de cette politique monétaire
c'est ce que Tom Benoît vient de dire
c'est le côté bulle il a parlé de la
bulle immobilierre quand vous mettez
beaucoup d'argent dans une économie avec
des taux d'intérêt zéro qu'est-ce que se
passe il se passe qu' y a beaucoup
d'emprunt il y a pas beaucoup
d'investissement je viens de le dire
mais il y a beaucoup d'emprunt on
emprinte
et on emprunte notamment pour acheter de
l'immobilier mais on achète de
l'immobilier déjà fait de du vieux et
donc on ne crée pas un m carré
supplémentaire
on si Madame A achète son appartement
dans le 16e arrondissement et qu'elle le
revend 6 mois après avec une plusvalue
considérable
Laur il n'y a pas eu de création de
richesse il y a eu une bulle il y a eu
l'augmentation des prix alors il est
évident que quand vous donnez des prêts
immobilier à taux extrêmement faible ce
qui a été le cas depuis 15 ans euh les
gens qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils
empreintent et ils vont acheter de
l'immobilier mais ils achètent de
l'immobilier existant c'est-à-dire que
ils augmente la valorisation d'un
patrimoine existant mais pas sa valeur
pas son extension ça c'est donc le
phénomène de la bulle il a atteint
l'immobilier mais il a aussi atteint les
obligations les obligations ont monté
contre toute
euh je dirais contre toute raison
Jacques je pourrais vous couper
je vous laisse terminer mais je vous
coupe encore un point le le point ultime
que j'ai c'est celui de des inégalités
sociales quand vous créez avec de
l'argent fictif quand vous créez de la
richesse sous forme de bulle immobilière
ou mobilière qui avantagez vous vous
avantagez les quelques ils sont à peu
près 10 % de la population qui ont accès
à ce genre de spéculation et c'est pas
le travailleur de base parce qu'il a pas
assez de réserve pour acheter un
appartement dans le
16e le résultat c'est que l'inégalité
sociale qui est un fait général de nos
sociétés s'accuse s'aggrave avec ce
phénomène et elle s'aggrave d'une
manière
considérable autrement dit quand vous
avez une économie
monétarisée
financierisé comme je le dis dans mes
livres et qui ne produit pas plus ou
très peu plus mais qui distribue
beaucoup d'argent au plus riches d'entre
nous vous avez une bombe sociale mais
vous vous éloignez totalement de
l'économie réelle surtout et vous vous
oui parce que le système il est
financiarisé j'ai j'ai calculé avec le
cabinet
mckinse que depuis 20 an 75 % de
l'augmentation du bilan global du monde
qui savent
calculer vient de valorisation
d'augmentation de valorisation et
seulement la différence c'estàdire 25 %
d'une croissance réelle de de l'économie
en terme
de d'addition si vous voulez à la à la
réalité donc quand vous prenez le métro
le matin
vous voyez les gens qui vont au bureau
voyez l'économie dans la rue il faut se
dire mais heureusement je dirais
politiquement pour ceux qui nous
gouvernent on ne se le dit pas mais moi
je le dis parce que c'est la vérité 75 %
du travail qui est fait par tout ce
mondeelà c'est de la valorisation
spéculative et 25 % seulement du boulot
de tous ces types ça va vers l'économie
réelle
alors vous pouvez dire au travailleurs
lambda que c'est une économie
parasitaire mais vous pouvez lui dire tu
sais c'est formidable le bilan global du
monde a triplé depuis quelques années le
type il vous
regarde comme si vous étiez un fada et
il vous dit mais moi qu'est-ce que j'ai
eu de ça ah non to toi tu n'as rien eu
parce que les salaires ont stagné mais
si tu étais dans les 10 % les plus
fortunés tu verrais ce que tu
gur et regardez l'endettement global au
bilan global également l'endettement
global c'est 360 % du PIB selon le bilan
global et encore pas selon les chiffres
du FMI que vous avez présidé Jacques qui
déclare je crois 240 ou 260 % du pb
parce que le FMI ne prend pas en
considération les l'endettement des
sociétés financières mais il faut
prendre en compte l'endettement des
sociétés financières parce qu'au final
ce qui impacte l'économie réelle c'est
également l'end des sociétés financières
ça veut dire que c'est l'Institut de la
finance internationale si mes souvenirs
sont bons qui nous communique des
chiffres très précis à 360 %
d'endettement global par rapport au PIB
et puis il y a un autre problème
également qui s'ajoute sont les
mécanismes d'émission monétairees parce
que lorsque l'émission monétaire bien
que trop accommodante comme le soulignit
JAC est-ce qui est très juste la planche
habillée la planche habillé comme on le
dit à l'occidental était opérée d'une
façon plutôt conventionnelle
c'est-à-dire par le BIS de B commerciale
qui faisait augmenter on va dire leur le
le leur crédit au au comptees qu'ell
détiennent auprès de la banque centrale
à laquelle elles étaient affilié il y
avait pas vraiment de problème parce
qu'on créait de la monnaie on la faisait
disparaître quelques temps puisque
stéris on l'a stérilisé on l'a créé puis
on l'a faisait disparaître lorsque les
crédits étaient remboursés et
aujourd'hui l'essentiel de la création
monétaire durant ces dernières années a
été opéré non pas par le biais des
banques commerciales mais par
assouplissement quantitatif ce qu'on
appelle le quantitativising
outreAtlantique ça veut dire que vous
avez des banques centrales qui achètent
des titres obligataires si on prend
l'exemple de la Banque centrale
européenne lorsque Maastrich a été signé
en 1992 et la Banque centrale européenne
créée en 1999 mise en service de l'euro
en 2002 il était bien précisé que la
banque centrale ne devait à aucun cas se
procurer les titres obligataires émis ou
ayant été émis donc sur les marchés
secondaires par les pays membres de la
la banque centrale donc je vous coupe
tous les deux donc on se rend compte que
l'indépendance des banqu centrale c'est
plus trop ça on se rend compte que nos
politiques distribuent de l'argent
magique mais attention elles étaient
obligé de le faire également c'est là où
il y a une double problématique donc il
distribue de l'argent magique ça a
commencé
2008 parce que le le le sy le système
monétaire avait besoin de liquidité
parce que les gens les banques avaient
peur de se prêter de la liquidité ou
donc ben Bern a reçu l'équivalent du
prix Nobel de l'économie je vous vois de
de lgé de la tête au nom de Ben bernan
Jacques comment ça se fait moi j'ai vécu
les deux phases parce que je suis très
vieux 94 ans c'est c'est un bon âge pour
commencer non mais c'est quand même une
étendue de de vie assez assez
exceptionnel j'ai donc connu la
phase où les banques centrales n'étaient
pas indépendante elles étaient
dépendantes c'était le gouvernement qui
décidait de la politique monétaire et la
banque centrale mettait en œuvre j'ai
connu ce régime quand j'étais gouverneur
de la Banque de France c'était ce régime
la la loi étaitune clarté absolue
c'était qui votre patron à l'époque
comment c'était qui votre patron le
président de la République à l'époque le
président de la République cétait
miteran et le ministre des Finances
c'était Beru
bergovo donc le le jeu était clair la
banque centrale était
dépendante du gouvernement je me
souviens très bien d'une de ma première
entrevue comme gouverneur de la Banque
de France avec le ministre des Finances
qui était ber goois qui é d'ailleurs un
très bon ministre des Finances
et je lui ai dit dans le premier
entretien que j'ai eu avec lui je
revenais du Fond Monétaire International
lui a dit monsieur le ministre je
connais la loi la loi veut que ce soit
vous qui décidiez de la politique
monétaire et que ce soit moi qui la
mette en
œuvre je connais cette loi et elle sera
appliquée mais je voulais vous signaler
le premier jour de notre rencontre que
si dans l'exercice de votre fonction de
maître de la politique monétaire d'après
la loi vous vous alliez dans une
direction qui me paraissait très
négative très mauvaise pour la stabilité
du franc je vous préviens je donnerai ma
démission aussitôt alors il m'a dit mais
écoutez c'est la première fois qu'on se
parle et vous me parlez déjà de
démission je lui dit non je ne vous
parle
pas de démission à perpétuité je vais
vous en parler exclusivement aujourd'hui
pour vous dire que si vraiment
l'orientation que vous donnez n'est pas
la bonne à à mon gré je m'en irai et je
m'en irai sans tambour ni trompette
alors on s'est très bien entendu
après il a été un défenseur admirable du
front et je n'ai jamais eu la moindre
critique à son égard mais j'avais posé
les lignes j'avais dit au-delà d'un
certain degré de d' mement je m'en vais
moi parce que vous êtes patriote comment
parce que vous êtes patriote parce que
j'ai le sens de ma mission si je suis à
la tête de la Banque de France ce qui
était le cas je suis responsable de la
stabilité de la monnaie si la Besse met
à fondre et que mes citoyens perdent
leur argent je ne suis pas dans ma
mission donc je lui ai dit ça et et ça
s'est très bien passé mais donc c'est la
première re partie c'est vous aviez des
banquiers centraux qui étaient dans la
main du gouvernement mais il pouvait ils
étaient rares d'ailleurs il pouvaent
être indépendant d'esprit mais pas dans
les textes ça c'était la première phase
qui a été ce qu'elle a été c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a eu de
l'inflation quand dans les années 70 on
a décidé que l'inflation allait trop
loin que Volker est arrivé au début des
années 80 et à casser l'inflation par le
choc volcire le fameux choc volcire ouis
oui par en augmentant les taux oui par
un choc en cassant la demande oui les
taux on monté à 20 % c'est qui passe un
peu en ce moment non oui mais il y avait
de la croissance à l'époque c'est la
grande différence oui oui mais commence
pas a cassé
l'inflation et en la cassant il a créé
une récession très importante et
mondiale donc il faut pas il faut faut
comprendre à ce moment-là on a dit
il faut donner l'indépendance aux
banques centrale parce que les
gouvernements ont montré pendant toutes
les années 70 qui n'était pas capable
de bloquer l'inflation on va maintenant
donner une autre un autre profil
statutaire aux banquiers centraux on va
les rendre
juridiquement responsable de la
stabilité monétaire indépendamment des
des gouvernements alors ça c'est la
deuxième phase dans laquelle nous sommes
encore cette deuxemème phase je m'excuse
de le
dire devant mes banquiers centraux s'il
y en a qui écoute l'émission n'a pas
fonctionné comme on l'aurait souhaité
pourquoi parce
que on s'est mis à créer beaucoup de
monnaie étant indépendant tout ce que je
vous ai raconté c'est sous le saut de
l'indépendance on a créé beaucoup de
monnaie on a créé beaucoup de problèmes
on a créé des
vulnérabilités majeures avec les taux
d'intérêt zéro on a fait tout ça en
étant
indépendant et dans ces choses que l'on
faisait il y a ce que vous avez dit il y
a que à partir d'un certain
moment c'est comme dans la pièce de
Jules Romain que personne ne lit plus et
qui s'appelle monsieur lerou ADC un
professeur charmant dans la province
monsieur le trouadc saisi par la
débauche et c'est une pièce charmante et
très intéressante et là les banquiers
centraux saisis par la débauche entre
guillemets se sont mis ou pas ou pas
entre guillemets
d'Illes se sont mis à faire du Qi
quantitative easing de l'assouissement
quantitatif c'est l'assouplissement
quantiitatif c'est-à-dire que j'achète
moi banquier central des titres
notamment des titres gouvernementaux
c'estàd ceux qui sont émis par les
ministres des Finances pour boucler le
budget à fixe je les ai mis je les
achète moiiv à tout fixe oui je les
achète et je les mets dans mon
portefeuille donc vous cré moi quand je
suis arrivé à la Banque de France on m'a
dit il y a un truc qu'il faut jamais
faire c'est acheter un titre que la
banque centrale achète un titre nouis
metteurs de monie achè des titres
obligataires il cré de mon ils ont fait
le pire des dépêcher qui consiste à
acquérir des titres publics parce que
c'est merveilleux pour les ministrre des
finances les taux sont à zéro vous avez
un monsieur un banquier central qui vous
dit j'achète tous les titres que vous
émettez vous faites un déficit énorme
PAP c'est pas grave je je vais le
financer et en plus ça vous coûte zéro
ils sont sous curatel ces gens-là
is ils sont sous curatel les banquiers
centraux vous Prz exemple que
vouszemple
l'histoire est folle l'histoire est
folle alors ils se sont mis à acheter
ces titres évidemment ça a soulagé les
les budgets ça les a soulagé
formidablement et donc ça a soulagé les
politiques intérieures bah donc ça
empêcher toute ESS de réforme des
budgets publics parce que qu'est-ce que
vous voulez un ministre des Finances
c'est c'est un homme et on lui dit tu as
de l'argent à zéro et tu en as
indéfiniment il va pasembêter à faire
des réformes de structure qui vont le
rendre impopulaire le résultat c'est que
alors je termine sur mon indépendance
des banques centrales c'est que le
deuxème acte de l'indépendance s'est
terminé bizarrement par une indépendance
qui a créé une dépendance phénoménale à
l'égard du gouvernement parce que quand
vous avez acheté la moitié de la dette
publique d'un pays vous êtes à ce pays
si vous commencez à retirer l'argent les
taux vont montés vous tuez le pays donc
vous êtes dans une situation qui est
redevenue par un biais de folie qui est
redevenu une situation de dépendance
alors c'est une c'est un résumé
peut-être un peu un peu ironique si vous
voulez de l'histoire de l'indépendance
des banques centrales mais c'est mais
c'est la vérité ok deux choses
jacqu on va essayer de de de résumer la
situation plus trivialement
imaginez-vous vous avez des gouvernants
addictes en totale dépendance de la
monnaie comme un héroïnoman avec sa cam
et là vous avez un dealer qui dit ne
t'inquiète pas mon pépère tous les jours
tu auras ta cam tous les jours ce sera
le même tarif fais-toi plaisir et là il
y a le médecin qui dit bon faut
peut-être arrêter vos conneries parce
que toi tu vas faire beaucoup d'argent
lui il va perdre sa santé et infin tu
auras plus de boulot et lui il sera mort
la question que je pose Jacques est-ce
qu'il y a des gens pour réguler les les
les gens qui ont pris le contrôle les
fous qui ont pris le contrôle de l'asile
est-ce qu'il y a des gens capables de
faire hop hop hop hop hop là là tu es en
pleine montée il faut arrêter tes
bêtises là tu risques la vie des
salariés là tu es en train de tuer ton
organ productif quels sont les
régulateurs de ces gens-là me dites pas
le bulletin des urnes l'urne le bulletin
dans l'urne les la subordnation sociale
avec de l'argent gratuit ça marche très
bien les gens ador donc je reformule ma
question qui est censé contrôler les
fous de
l'asile la réponse à votre question est
très simple c'est normalement à la
banque centrale de faire cette
régulation et de se auto censurer mais
elle ne le fait pas au contraire elle
abonde
elle abonde dans le sens de
l'accommodation monétaire et de la et de
la création monétaire alors on peut
imaginer ta cravate
pardon oui on peut imaginer que il y ait
un organe supérieur à la banque centrale
qui contrôle la banque centrale ça c'est
toujours ce qui et vient à l'esprit
quand un système institutionnel
fonctionne mal on dit oui mais on va
rajouter un truc
au-dessus ce truc au-dessus existe alors
il y a la baerie mais la berie n'a pas
de pouvoir mais il y a un organisme au
niveau de la Banque centrale
européenne qui est chargé de vérifier le
la cohérence macro-économique de
l'ensemble cet organe comment il
s'appelle cet organe s'appelle le le
bureau des infirmières non j'ai le nom
c'est c'est je je le retrouverz en cours
de conversation mais son nom n'est pas
très important parce que il aimait des
recommandations d'un caractère général
il n'aimait jamais de recommandations
sur ce que je viens de vous dire dans l'
sur les les les choses importantes il
est toujours un peu à la marge des
choses et et pourquoi est-il
si bénévolant parce qu'il fait partie de
la Banque centrale européenne donc il
est ben oui qu'est-ce que vous vouz
c'est on critique pas son patron et et
donc ça ne marche pas alors la raison
fondamentale pour laquelle les banquiers
centraux se sont engagés dans cette
politique folle le taux d'intérêt zéro
est-ce que je peux dire ont vendu leur
âme au diable est-ce que je peux
requalifier ça de ils ont vendu leur âme
au diable oui en fait ça dépend comment
on défend le comment on définit le
diable
ce qui est vrai c'est que ils ont
abandonné une des bases de la politique
monétaire que je vais vous rappeler
c'est que quand on crée trop de monnaie
face à une économie molle ou peu
croissante à la longue ce trop de
monnaie va finir dans
l'inflation celui qui a trouvé ce cette
vérité économique s'appelle Jean
il écrivait en
1558 et il a démontré mathématiquement
que quand il y avait trop de monnaie par
rapport à des besoins de financement peu
élevés ça finissait par l'inflation son
théorème n'a jamais été démenti il a été
repris par l'école des de Friedman aux
États-Unis très longtemps après et qui
qui a affiné les concepts mais le
principe est toujours là quel est le
principe que nos banquiers sans trop
ceux qui font l'objet de la critique que
je me permets de leur adresser quel est
le principe qu'ils n'ont jamais regardé
c'est le principe de de Jean Baudin
c'est le principe de ce qu'on appelle th
la théorie quantitative de la monnaie il
n'ont jamais regardé
et plus je dirais plus ironiquement le
patron de la Fedde américaine qui
s'appelle monsieur
a dit il y a 2 ans à l'époque où on lui
disait au Parlement au Congrès américain
on lui rapport entre le volume de la
monnaie et l'inflation oui lui disait
quand même vous créez beaucoup de
monnaie par rapport à une économie qui
est peu florissante ça en général ça se
termine par l'inflation et il a répondu
cette chose qui m'a qui m'a cloué au sol
il a dit non c'est fini ça le principe
de la théorie quantitative de la monnaie
ne
s'exécute se vérifie plus depuis je plus
2017 c'est comme si vous disiez la loi
de la gravitation universelle ah non non
non depuis 7 ans c'est fini il y a plus
de gravitation universelle c'est absurde
et bien sûr qui s'exerce ce principe et
on est en train d'en supporter les
conséquences aujourd'hui Jacques les
banquiers centraux est-ce qu'ils sont
pénalement responsables de leur conom
non non non la réponse c'est non et il y
a quelqu'un qui est responsable
pénalement dans une banque centrale ou
non non non il serait responsable
pénalement s'il commettait des
irrégularités manifestes mais c'est pas
le cas l'irrégularité manifeste non
c'est pas une irrégularité parce que le
le sophisme qui est
derrière
l'achat pratiquement illimité de titre
d'État et privé si je ne le fais pas
tout va se casser la figure c'est ça
c'est oui enfin c'est plus élaboré que
ça c'est banquiers mais on n'est pas
très loin parce que si la banque
centrale n'avait pas acheté des titres
obligataires comme elle l'a fait le
système aurait fait faillite alors vous
allez me dire on état ne peut pas faire
faillite avant avant avant ils auraient
simplement av agi avant ça n'aurait pas
été la même chose mais ils
ont ils ont un
sophisme c'est toujours utile le
sophisme parce que ça vous permet de
justifier
l'injustifiable et ils disent non
non il faut qu'une politique monétaire
puisse se diffuser puisse se transmettre
à l'économie si nous ne faisons rien au
titre de l'achat des titres publics
l'économie risque d'être en péril parce
que nous ne l'aurons pas irrigué
suffisamment et que comme nous sommes à
zéro nous butons sur ce qu'on
appelle la frontière du taux zéro c'est
un problème arithmétique que je vais
vous livrer parce que il vaut la
peine je vous ai dit que les taux
d'intérêt étaient à zéro c'est un fait
quand vous avez des taux d'intérêt à
zéro et que vous voulez relancer
l'économie davantage par des taux
d'intérêt plus FAI vous ne le pouvez pas
pourquoi parce que
zéro c'est pas facile de briser le zéro
si vous ouvez mettre les taux à Z0 mais
mettre les taux à - 1 2 3 5 c'est pas
possible parce que vous avez à ce
moment-là un tel détournement un tel un
tel tel brimade de l'épargne parce que
si vous mettez de l'argent de côté vous
êtes taxé à 5 c'est pas possible que
avecinfltion on est on est taxé à pas
possible je parle pas de l'inflation je
parle en général vous ne pouvez pas pas
aller à moins très substantiellement
donc vous êtes bloqué à 0 0,2 0,3 vous
êtes bloqué là donc
disait-il vous ne pouvez plus faire de
la relance budgétaire par le taux
d'intérêt puisque vous êtes bloqué par
l'arithmétique alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et c'est là qu'on
fait ce que Tom Benoît a très bien
décrit on fait on achète des titres de
manière illimitée et on crée de la
monnaie et quand on crée de la monnaie
pour acheter des titres la monnaie elle
est là elle est elle est chez les les
vendeurs de titres elle est partout et
et donc ils ont fait
ça alors alors je reviens à votre
question est-ce qu'ils sont pénalement
responsables la réponse c'est non parce
que ils ont le droit d'acheter des
titres mais surtout ils ont sauvé le
système avec ça parce que s'il le
faisait pas le système faisait faillite
oui enfin on s pas sûr qu'il ferait
faillite mais certains feraient faillite
dans dans le système c'est ce qui est un
peu différent et ceux les plus exposés
et mais tous les travailleurs qui font
90 % de la population ils sont pas
directement exp donc c'est quand même un
peu particulier mais il vous disent j'ai
le droit de le faire si mon sentiment
appuyé par mes services techniques et
pour mon conseil d'administration pense
qu'il est de bonne politique de vou voir
faciliter l'expansion la communication
la transmission de la politique
monétaire que nous faisons par le jeu de
l'achat de titrre nous pouvons le faire
c'est un vieil instrument qui a toujours
été là il était en Angleterre au 17e
siècle si vous avez un jour un peu de
trop insuffisante liquidité entre les
banques et que les taux risques de
devenir fou la banque centrale peut
injecter des des titres Jacques je peux
vous couper oui vous avez un bilan de
santé quand vous êtes banquier central
banquier on devrait en avoir un donc on
devrait c'estd qu'il y en a pas c'est on
vérifie pas votre santé mentale on
vérifie pas si vous êtes sous influence
si vous prenez des cacheton si vous
jouez au jeu si vous avez une
consommation trancière de
péripathéticienne mais qui va le faire
ce bilan de santé c'est la banque
centrale elle-même qui va le faire un
peu comme les agences de notation quand
vous lisez
les 20
opuscule annuel des banques centrales
depuis 20 ans qui lit ça mis à part non
mais ils ont leur publication annuelle
comme toutes les sociétés qu'est-ce que
vous lisez vous lisez la phrase de
Voltaire tout va pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes
alors c'est marqué noir sur blanc ça non
mais c'est c'est c'est ça que ça veut
dire et puis c'est la communication de
tous les dirigeants politiques qui est
monétaire depis des ann alors moi je je
pense que on aurait mieux fait d'avoir
un groupe de pour répondre à votre
question là je suis en plein dans votre
préoccupation au lieu
d'avoir une émanation de la Banque
centrale européenne qui fait ce travail
d'analyse médicale si je puis dire du
système au lieu d'avoir ça j'aurais
préféré qu'il y ait un organe détaché de
la Banque centrale rien à voir avec elle
indépendant avec des économistes des
professeurs d'université des policiers
non des juges des des experts non pas
des politiques des experts des experts
des gens qui ont travaillé sur la
monnaie et et ces gens-là feraient un
rapport annuel pour
dire il y a trop d'albumine il y a trop
de créatinine il y a trop il y a pas
assez c'est de
leucocy c'est ça que je voudrais moi
et j'ai même écrit ça et un prof de
médecine m'a écrit volontairement il m'a
dit mais j'ai vu votre clin d'œil pour
les analyses médicales si un patient et
son
médecin n'avait aucun intérêt pour le
résultat de de l'analyse de laboratoire
on dirait ils sont fous ça veut dire la
première des choses c'est de regarder
les chiffres sur si vous prenez
l'exemple en France et en Europe reg
depuis la création de Al moi je prêche
ça je prêche ça mais je suis un individu
isolé je désolé donc on va en discuter
Tom entre 2002 et 2008 on lance l'euro
donc la Banque centrale européenne
imprime beaucoup de monnais parce qu'il
fallait irriguer dans le système
monétaire de la monnaie à l'imprime de
l'Euro 2008 il y a la crise des dettes
souveraines la crise grecque il y a un
climat de frilosité monétaire on imprime
plus de monnaie de 2008 à 2015 à peu
près et vous regardez la courbe de
l'inflation en France donc puisqu'il y
avait pas d'autonomie monétaire mais que
c'était la Banque centrale européenne
qui qui devenait le le garant de la
monnaiee en France la courbe d'inflation
entre 2002 et 2020 se situe environ
entre 1 et 2 % elle chute en 2015 à 0 et
au plus haut en 2008 à 2,8 ou 3 %
environ mais l'inflation est plutôt
jugulée assez stable et en 2021 en
seulement 12 mois vous passez donc en
une année de 1,6 à 5,6 % et pourquoi
est-ce que vous passez en seulement 12
mois pour la première fois de l'histoire
de l'euro et de cette histoire monétaire
de 16 à 5,6 parce que pendant 6 ans
pendant les 6 précédentes années vous
avez imprimé de la monnaie mais vous
n'avez pas irriguer l'économie réelle
vous avez fait de l'assouplissement
quantitatif alors pour que les gens
comprennent bien on a imprimé combien de
milliers de milliards entre 2015 et
2021 5000 6000 milliards je vais vous
donner un chiffre exact si vous prenez
la dette aujourd'hui la dette courante
c'est 3000 milliards vous avez 52 % de
dette extérieur donc détenu par des
prêteurs extérieurs et sur ces
50essources le l'Agence France Trésor
mais j'ai échangé à ce propos avec Bruno
le mer d'ailleurs et c'est à faire ouii
je je je m'adresse aux experts et donc
l'Agence France bricolage ça marche
aussi hein mais en tout cas Monsieur
Bruno le on va rediriger vers France
Trésor qui est l'organisme chargé
d'émission de dette le rayon tournevis
effectivement si vous allez sur le site
de l'Agence France Trésor vous
découvrirez qu'il y a 52 % de la dette
française qui est détenue par des
prêteurs étrangers dans ces 52 % à
l'intérieur il y a combien de dictateurs
il y a combien de puissan qui ça je
pourais pas vous dire mais ils sont
probablement chinois ou russes en tout
cas à vous parlez non je vous parlez des
détente d'Arabie Saoudite américain
aussi parce que c'est dans les usages
les Américains ont toujours acheté en
toujours tendre la laisse en réalité
j'ai posé la question à TR ministres de
l'économie et des finances AR Mbour a
fait une réponse assez précise en me
disant que beaucoup de Chinois
détenaient de la date française
effectivement Alain Madelin qui est
brillantissime a fait une réponse très
détaillée également Bruno le ma m'
diriger vers France Trésor
et donc à l'intérieur de ces 52 % ce que
je voulais dire c'est que vous avez 50 %
donc 25 % de la dette totale qui est
logée à la Banque centrale européenne
aujourd'hui donc ça veut dire que sur
3000 milliards pour répondre très
exactement à votre question vous P faire
le calcul vous avez 25 % de 3000
milliards aujourd'hui détenu par la
Banque centrale européenne ce qui nous
fait mais bah ce qui nous fait 25 % vous
êtes à ce ce 100
750 millions d'euros broutille et une
broutille puisque on s'est endetté à
nouveau de près de 300 millions pour
cette année de 270 et donc si vous allez
plus loin que ça
c'est que le le grand danger aujourd'hui
le gros danger c'est que le
quantitativising ne puisse plus opérer
et qu'il faille opérer cette fois-ci à
l'effacement partiel des bilans de la
Banque centrale et là si vous vous
mettez à effacer une partie du bilan de
la banque centrale c'est tout le système
que vous mettez à mal non c'est c'est la
crédibilité d'abord c'est la crédibilité
de la monnaie mais la monnaie repose
essentiellement sur la crédibilité euh
un billet de 100 € c'est 8 centimes je
voudrais rajouter deux choses à ce qu'a
dit Tom Benois qui est très exact et je
vous jette euh en passant on fera une
petite parenthèse sur la militarisation
de la
dette la militarisation la
militarisation de la dette par
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
alors essentiellement sanctions et
autres ouais alors deux choses que je
voulais rajouter sont les suivantes la
première c'est
que en achetant des titres
massivement après la crise de 2008 faut
comprendre ce qu'est la crise de 2008 la
crise de 2008 c'est une crise où
l'endettement excessif que j'ai décrit
d'une manière critique tout à l'heure
l'endettement excessif du système
c'est profondément détérioré et a donné
lieu à une crise financière parce que il
y avait des gens qui avaient emprunté
qui n'étaient pas pas susceptible de
rembourser donc vous avez eu une CR il y
avait des gens qui leuront prêté sans
sans avoir vérifié queils étaient bien
sûr puisque l'argent était à zéro alors
on a donc eu une crise financière je
dirais classique où les les mauvais
débiteurs ou les débiteurs fragiles ont
fait faillite et à ce moment-là c'est
tout le marché qui s'est retourné parce
que quand vous avez un phénomène de ce
genre même les bons débiteurs
sont pénalisés par la crise parce que le
marché se retourne c'est toutes les
perspectives qui changent
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a fait le le
pouvoir américain la Fed que nous
suivons comme comme des benets oui enfin
suivant très très trèsc très docilement
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il s'est mis à
racheter les titres qui étaient vendus
sur le marché à villeprix
pourquoi faire pour éviter la faillite
du système et j'ajoute toujours et la
perte que subiraient les individus qui
avaient été suffisamment imprudents pour
acheter ces titres ça s'appelle le
hasard moral et le hasard moral c'est
une expression un peu pédante mais qui
veut dire une chose très simple c'est
que quand les capitalistes qui ont
acheté des
titres douteux mais le savz se voit se
voit frappé par un retournement de
marché il y a un PER Noël qui vient et
qui dit je vais te les racheter à
meilleur prix que ce que le marché peut
fournir et qu'est-ce qu'on dit là et
c'est ce qu'on appelle Noël une
assurance mais cette assurance n'est pas
n'est pas officielle personne ne la
connaît elle n'a pas de prime que vous
ayez à payer mais elle joue elle joue
parce que les pouvoirs publics hésitent
à laisser la crise se développer parce
qu'ils ont peur que elle se généralise
et qu'elle ne bloque complètement
l'économie ça c'est la première chose
que je voulais dire vous avez pour les
gens qui se sont exposés exagérément
l'histoire le dit vous avez une garanti
une assurance sans prime qui vous sort
d'affaire le mieux possible ce qu'on
appelle le hasard moral il vient de se
développer aux États-Unis vous avez vu
qu'il avait une banque dans l'ouest des
États-Unis qui s'appelle la Silicon
Valley ban qui était pourri de QI acheté
à prix zéro et quand les taux ont
commencé à remonter les trucs qui n'av
pas d'assurance sur OUI à ce momentl ça
ça perd ça c'était la grande banque des
sociétés de la tech qui plait qui avait
des réserves de liquidité considérables
c'est qu'on a eu un un sur une banque on
a une feuille bancaire sur une banque
qui avait PL tort de réserve detilité
alors mais
rassurez-vous les gens très fortunés qui
avaient mis leur argent dans la silicone
Valberg sont complètement garantis par
l'État c'est l'État leur a dit vous
aurez le dernier set de vos affaires
vous vous les aurez donc hasard moral et
l'autre chose que je voulais dire c'est
que le système marche sur la tête sans
déconn
mais le fait de vouloir
instaurer des taux d'intérêt à 0 % est
une folie intellectuelle parce que toute
économie se finance bonant malant par
l'éparg et les parges des ménages
essenti pares des ménages finance 90 %
de l'économie sur longue période 90 % le
type qui m'apporte 90 % de mon
investissement je lui dis va te
faire tuas
zéro c'est il faut quand même c'est
audacieux était le pilier des démocratie
libérale on parlait dans les années 70
et 80 des démocraties libéral tout notre
environnement enfin c'est les caisses
d'éparne mais JAC tu comprends rien tu
sais pourquoi tu es trop puriste que tu
es trop puriste c'est-à-dire que quand
je vous entends quand je t'entends pour
moi tu es trop puriste tu ne peux pas
comprendre que ces gens sont soit
malsins soit médiocres et ils sont cuul
et chemises avec un pouvoir politique
qui est coincé soit par des ressources
énergétiques soit par des matières
premières soit par des pays béliqueux
qui ne veulent pas vendre à leur tarif
et il se retrouvent coincé par la su
auquel on veut pas acheter ou il se
retrouveent coincé par le phénomène de
subornation de vote votez pour moi je
suis le président du pouvoir d'achat
l'année prochaine ça ira mieux tout tout
le monde sera content on aura tous deux
maisons trois voitures et on aura des
voitures volantes et la chose est la
suivante c'est que comme en
thermodynamique quand il y a de
l'instabilité on voit qui est-ce qui est
à poil et là à l'heure actuelle on a
l'impression que les gouver
et les banques centrales sont en
faillite que ce soit moral ou monétaire
et que on maintient le vernis social le
temps que ça fonctionnera jusqu'à ce que
l'hyperinflation aille mordre dans les
supermarchés et que les politiques se
mettent à courir le 100 m en moins de 10
secondes donc la question que je me pose
il faut quel type de personne pour
remettre les choses à plat et carré
parce que tel que je vois la chose se
dérouler devant nous ça n'augure que des
mauvaises choses pour les générations
futures pas d'investissement futur on
voit une caste parasitaire se payer sur
les investissements passés de ta
génération Jacques des investissements
qui ont été faits pour notre génération
donc tous ceux qui ont une soixantaine
d'années se payent sur la bête ça va mal
se terminer
toi avec ton grand âge 94 ans tuon as vu
passer des hivers tu le sens comment ils
vont se rattraper aux branches ils vont
être barbouillés de de de goudron avec
des plumes ils vont nous
sortir un mécanisme du chapeau magique
ils sont responsables mais pas coupables
comment tu vois les choses venir et Tom
dans la foulée tu tu tu représenteras la
génération de mainant tu viens de
poser la question fondamentale parce que
c'est la question politique c'est c'est
pas possible que tous ces typesl a
commis les mêmes erreurs absurdes et que
ils ai fait tout ça alors je partage en
grande
partie le souci qui
t'inspire
mais je le formulerai d'une manière un
peu
différente je dis
ceci
si on ne comprend
pas le phénomène de la financierisation
de notre monde qui est celui que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure 75 % de la
richesse vient en réalité de la
spéculation et favorise 10 % de la
population alors que 90 % de la
population se sert la satature ça c'est
la vérité c'est ce qu'on appelle la
financierisation nous sommes peu à la
dénoncer
euh tu tu te trouves ce soir en présence
de quelqu'un qui le fait et qui aa fait
dans un livre qui a eu beaucoup de
retentissement qui s'appelle le règne de
l'illusion financière et l'illusion
financière c'est ça alors c'est un
phénomène
fondamental parce que il dicte la
croissance des inégalités social et il
dicte le contenu inflationniste qui
finit par exploser de notre système
c'est fondamental alors qui est
responsable de cette vague de
financiérisation du fait que 75 % de la
richesse c'est de la blague et 25 %
c'est pour les les malheurotypes qui qui
se crèvent la la la fin
alors là-dessus on peut avoir des idées
différentes moi j'ai mon interprétation
que je vais vous
livrer c'est pas grave si je prends
quelques minutes bon mon interprétation
est la
suivante ce qui a rendu possible cette
financiérisation du système c'est
l'abandon du système de taux de change
fixe après la guerre les Américains qui
étaient les victorieux de la guerre ont
créé un système où chaque monnaie était
définie par une relation avec le dollar
pourquoi Nixon a tué Breton Wood bah
cétait le système de Breton Wood parce
qu'il n'avait plus suffisamment d'or
tout simplement et parce que l'Allemagne
venait frapper à la porte des Américains
parce que les Japonais également ont
demandé de l'or et le dollar la France
également et d'ailleurs degol avait un
point de vue assez corrosif quelques
années auparavant c'était le 15 août
1971 la fin de la convertibilité du
dollar àord annoncé par Nixon oui ça ça
c'est l'historique mais ce que je veux
ce que je veux expliquer
c'est les conséquences de l'abandon du
système de Breton Woods et de la
convertibilité en hord du doll les
conséquences ont été les suivantes alors
là il faut un peu s'accrocher mais je
vais le dire très
simplement si l'abandon du système de
Breton Woods s'était traduit par le
flottement généralisé des monnaies on
aurait pu le concevoir
mais ça ne s'est pas produit ce qui
s'est produit c'est une espèce
de d'anarchie sur le marché deschanges
il y en avait qui défendaient leur
monnaie parce qu'il voulaient pas
qu'elle
se tombe trop il y en avait d'autres qui
voulaient qu'elle tombe pour des
avantages
commerciaux bon c'était le
désordre et ce
désordre règne encore aujourd'hui si
nous vivons euh comme en 1973 h et de ce
point de
vue-là alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
moi je m'en souviens très bien parce que
j'étais aux affaires lorsque j'étais
dans le régime de bretonuse dans le
régime de Breton j'étais au trésor
j'étais pas le directeur encore c'était
dans les années 60 on gagnit combien à
cette époque làà oui ben j'étais au
trésor depuis 58 59 c'est quel salaire
hein on gagne combien quand on est au TR
oh c'était des salaires modestes je sais
pas 2000 € d'aujourd'hui bon c'est
pas pas le PDG de du CAC 40
mais donc on était là et moi quand
j'allais au bureau physiquement j'étais
inquiet de la relation entre le franc et
le dollar parce qu'elle était obligée
elle était fixée par le Fond monétaire
nationale et si on dérangeait à ça si on
disait oui ben on s'en fout on va
dévaluer on pouvait pas parce qu'on
avait pas le droit de dévaluer fallait
aller à Washington avec sa canne et son
chapeau et demander au directeur général
du FMI une négociation pour voir si on
pouvait dévaluer la monnaie donc c'était
un système très rigide et moi je me
souviens j'étais mais obnubilé
par l'égalité entre le Fran et et le et
le dollar américain qui était de règle
le jour où les États-Unis ont fichu en
les breton Woods en déclarant
l'inconvertibilité du dollar en or ce
jour-là qu'est-ce qui s
passé commcer a fait chacun a fait ce
qu'il voulait il y a pas eu un nouveau
régime disons désormais chacun flottera
en fonction de l'offre et de la demande
de la bnaie
Tom dit un truc très intéressant
c'est-à-dire que en empêchant la
convertibilité du dollar avec de l'or
ils ont multiplié les petits pains d'une
façon magique évidemment non ce qu'il
faut comprendre sur FA il y a eucuse je
term vousz pasus ce qui s'est passé
c'est que quand on a détruit le système
des taux de change fixe on n'est pas
vraiment entré dans les taux de change
flottant on est entré dans chacun fait
ce qu'il veut et ce chacun fait ce qu'il
veut a donné naissance à des des crédits
à des emprunts massive comprenez bien la
situation les États-Unis étaient en
déséquilibre de balance des paiements
structurel c'est-à-dire énorme et
persistant qu'est-ce qui se passe quand
on est dans un monde de marché de change
flottant il se passe que la monnaie
américaine qui a importé plus qu'elle
n'exporter ce serait détérioré or la
détérioration de la monnaie américaine
n'était pas désirée par le corps
politique américain parce que si vous
laissez votre monnaie se détériorer vous
devenez plus pauvre tout le monde
devient plus pauvre et les américains
ils ont pas envie d'être plus beau alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait des petites
guerres ils ont emprunté ils ont
emprunté de l'argent et pour pousser le
dollar à la hausse alors qu'il baissait
en tendantiellement au marché
et donc ils ont
été ils ont été addictes des emprunts
parce que les emprunts leur permettaient
de ne pas dévaluer brutalement dans un
monde où chacun ce qu'il voulait et
cette facilité qu'ils ont eu
d'emprunter pour Massager leur économie
si je peux dire a été phénoménal tout le
monde s'est mis à
emprunter le le jeune fonctionna du
trésor que j'étais dans les années 60
qui disait oh là là mais il faut pas que
le franc trébuchche de d'un millimère
par rapport à sa sa ligne de dollar
c'est fini ça tout le monde s'en foutait
c'était l'échang était devenu un truc
que que l'on que l'on régissait comme on
voulait résultat tout le monde s'est mis
à emprunter résultat tout le monde
continue à rempinter il y a pas de
discipline internationale n'existe pas
on emprunte on emprunte basé sur rien
mais on emprunte parce queil y a de
l'argent parce que les banques centrales
font la liquidité du marché parce qu'il
y a des pays également exportateurs
d'énergie et de matières premières qui
récupèent beaucoup de mon qui sont
partant
pour donc là là on va rebondir sur
quelque chose de très intéressant c'est
l'aspect guerre économique et la
militarisation de la
dette mais la militarisation de la dette
elle démarre l'épicentre c'est l'Arabie
Saoudite de la militarisation de la
dette et avec la protection des
Américains sur le Moyen-Orient et on
revient à la production de pétrole
principalement qui a été le grand moteur
du 20e siècle quelque chose de tangible
de tangible donc des matières premières
et énergétiques en l'occurrence ce qu' a
très bien résumé Jacques précédemment
c'est que vous avez trois phases vous
avez breton Woods en 1944 45
l'adossement à l'or donc une valeur
tangible c'est pas de la production mais
c'est une valeur on peut pas définir
exactement pourquoi mais certainement
par rapport à la crédibilité un peu
comme des monis Fiat l'or ne peut pas
s'effondrer d'une minute à l'autre et
d'un jour à l'autre le Bitcoin
plausiblement mais pas l'or pour le
moment et a déjà eu un audit de la Fed
en terme de réserve d'or ou non mais il
faudrait le faire et je soupçonne les
Américains d'avoir toujours menti je le
dis très clairement par rapport à leur
réserve d'or mais dès 1945 et je pense
que les Américains savaient très bien
lors de la signature des accords de
Breton Woods qu'ils ont imposé au reste
de l'Occident qu'ils ont imposé pour des
raisons tendraisjeà dire légitimes parce
qu'ils étaient les charmeurs de
l'Occident ils avaient un soft power qui
datait depuis la la la fin du 19e et qui
s'était totalement imposé après guerre
lorsqu'ils sont revenus chewingum Europe
les chewinggum et le chocolat américain
et à partir de là ils ont imposé breton
Woods et lorsqu'ils sortent de Breton
Woods et qu'apparaît les accords de la
Jamaïque les fameux taux de change
flottant on a à nouveau une vingtaine
d'années un petit peu chaotique qui
permet de relancer les États-Unis et là
vous avez un troisème événement c'est
l'instauration du marché obligataire
contemporain parce qu'on a l'impression
que le marché obligataire numérisé
contemporain existe depuis breton Woods
mais ça n'est pas le cas l'endettement
ne se faisait pas du tout de la même
façon en 1945 qu'en 1995 ou 2000 et là à
partir des années 90 vous avez
l'instauration de d'un système
obligataire qui permet un endettement
massif numérisé et démesuré auprès de
pays exportateurs qui sont obligés de se
refaire une santé donc essentiellement
les Chinois qui intègrent l'OMC mais par
la petite porte au part qui sont pas
très puissants je parlais du volume
monétaire global précédemment non c'est
très juste ce que ce que dit Tom est
très juste j'ajoute une chose bien sûr
bien sûr j'ajoute une chose la Chine a
été un grand exportateur de
produits bien de consommation produit
manufacturés de matières premièes et
elle a vendu tout ça contre des
dollars alors réfléchissez au phénomène
macroéconomique a vendu tout ça contre
de la dépendance un/ers de la monnaie
globale est logé en Chine aujourd'hui
mais
la les États-Unis sont en déficit
structurel c'est-à-dire ça continue tous
les ans qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'ils achètent plus de
produits qu'ils ne sont capables d'en
exporter
d'accord qui leur vend ces produits
qu'ils achètent la Chine en particulier
et la Chine qu'est-ce qu'elle obtient
des
dollars alors vous avez le phénomène
économique suivant la demande annuelle
américaine la demande courante est
financé par de l'emprunt américain ils
nont pas d'argent donc ils emprunent cet
emprunt va dans la poche des Chinois et
des saoui alors vous avez d'un côté un
pays qui consomme son je dirais son son
son quotidien avec de l'emprunt et vous
avez la Chine qui amasse des dollars
c'est-à-dire qui amasse de la puissance
parce que dans un cas ils ont bouffé le
leurs importations en une année dans
l'autre ils ont rien bouffé du tout ils
ont gardé leur de la il les font marcher
sur le marché
international et il garde la puissance
financière parce que elle est là
capitalisée chez alors certes on les
soumet à des
sanctions des opérations qui les gênent
et cetera mais il faut comprendre que le
transfert entre le le sud et le Nord si
vous voulez pour parler entre l'Est et
l'Ouest le transfert est très est très
pénalisant
géopolitiquement je suis les États-Unis
je consomme trop j'emprunte pour Sommer
trop et je je m'endête de plus en plus
et les Chinois j'exporte de la matière
premièr des des produits manufacturés
c'est-à-dire de la de la richesse que
j'ai créé moi Chine et en contrepartie
j'ai une puissance financière qui
devient accablante c'est ça le l'origine
ce qui est très intéressant la
contrepartie de ce que vient de
souligner très juste jacqu c'est
qu'aujourd'hui avec 27 trillions de
monnaie en dollars logé en Chine sur un
total de 89 trillions en monnaie globale
si la monnaie venait trillion c'est 1000
milliards 1000 milliards c'estut dire
89000 milliards et 27000 milliards logés
en Chine donc si la monnaie globale
venait à perdre de sa valeur d'une façon
croissante et régulière durant les mois
et les années à venir ce ne sont pas les
américains les plus gros perdants ce
sont les détenteurs de monnaie sont les
Chinois donc à partir de là tu parlais
précédemment des solutions les solutions
elles sont dramatiques principalement en
Occident parce qu'en Occident on
s'éloigne du schéma de démocratie
libérale c'est-à-dire de la capacité
d'entreprendre à égalité que l'on soit
riche ou pauvre en démarrant et on se
dirige vers une démagogie socialisée si
je puis dire donc non pas une démocratie
mais un régime démagogique socialisé
sous le masque de la bienveillance parce
que effectivement que les gens ne
peuvent plus se loger non plus ils n'ont
plus accès au crédit et demain ils
n'auront plus accès à l'emploi et demain
directement ils n'auront plus accès à
endettement non plus je te rassure avant
il y aura accès à la viande et à la
nourriture de qualité à l'électricité et
au chauffage ouais par Euro numérique
probablement plausiblement parce que on
assiste à cela également à la division
du système monétaire et ça c'est un
événement sans précédent donc la
dislocation géopolitique mondiale au
niveau
monétaire quand on voit les briques
s'émerger les bricks se renforcer les
bricks dire on va faire une monnaie
adossée à un panier de matières premièr
on l'or aussi d'ailleurs oui l'or est
une matière première Tom merci pour ce
conseil et financière quand on se
retrouve avec des bricks qui veulent se
dédollariser le plus vite possible et se
refocaliser sur la production les choses
tangibles comme les matières premières
quand en face on a quelqu'un qui a vécu
toujours par la dette avec le plus gros
pistolet qu'il y a sur les chiquier
comment ça se passe Jacques les
américains ils vont accepter cette
contestation d'hégémonie don question
ils vont arriver à dire bon on va se
mettre d'accord on est une société
mature dans un monde mature où les gens
se respectent ou bah on va vous faire
tomber comment ça se passe oui alors je
vous poser le grand débat géopolitique
d'aujourd'hui
euh moi je j'avance avec prudence dans
ce sur ce terrain mais je peux vous
confier quelques
pensées si
quelqu'un a l'esprit correctement bâti
pense qu'on va amener la Chine à un
système démocratique à la Suisse c'est
de la folie pure la Chine est un pays
qui a un système politique très
différent du nutre il est pas basé sur
le polypartisme il est pas basé sur les
élections libres il est pas basé sur les
droits de l'homme il est basé sur
l'efficacité du gouvernement central et
et du Parti communiste c'est un système
qui leur
convient parce que ils sont à milliard
et demi parce que
c'est c'est pas facile de diriger avec
nos méthodes parlementaires un pays
comme la Chine nous ne le changerons
pas personne ne le changera
et donc je pense qu'on serait une
planète plus paisible si on acceptait
que la Chine soit pas comme la France ou
les États-Unis ou la Grande-Bretagne il
faut accepter que ils ont un régime
politique différent ils l'ont d'ailleurs
eu pendant toute leur histoire
et et ça c'est la première chose deème
chose c'est
que la raison pour laquelle les
États-Unis se sont réveillés en disant
c'est intolérable de voir la Chine
devenir la première puissance économique
mondiale la raison pour laquelle il ne
l'accepte pas c'est pas que la Chine a
un régime non démocratique la raison
c'est que ça mine l'égé américaine c'est
ça la raison alors est-ce qu'ils ont
raison de vouloir en altérant le
commerce mondial libre en imposant des
sanctions aux importations qui leur
plaisent pas est-ce que c'est bien de
ralentir en quelque sorte l'ouverture du
système mondial qui a été considérable
depuis temps est-ce que c'est bien de
faire ça je n'en sais rien ralentir
gagner du temps comment ralentir ou
gagner du temps oui mais moi je ne suis
pas persuadé que ça soit une bonne
politique je pense que ce serait une
meilleure politique de comprendre un peu
mieux qui est le partenaire et
d'accepter des règles du jeu sur le plan
financier par différence avec ce qui se
passe sur le plan des biens et des
services les États-Unis conservent la
suprématie et il conserent la suprématie
parce qu'ils ont le grand marché
obligataire dont vous parliez et qui est
unique au monde vous voulez vendre une
une obligation aux États-Unis vous la
vendez immédiatement le marché est
profond vous trouvez un partenaire ça
n'existe pas à l'extérieur la Chine est
parfaitement consciente de cette
suprématie du dollar c'est làdessus tu
repose la grande hégémonie du dollar
encore aujourd'hui alors le grand sujet
justement est-ce que tu Liget très
justement c'est est-ce que les les
bricks assez largement on va dire la
Chine et les pays environnants parce que
le gros moteur quand même économique des
bricks c'est la Chine le moteur
démocratique entre guillemets c'est
l'Inde qui a aussi une grosse puissance
démographique la première du monde pas
très content tous les de et il y a pas
beaucoup il y a certaines illimitiés
entre les deux et puis il y a un pays
parmi les deux qui est un petit peu plus
occidental occidentalisé en tout cas
avec des proximités occidentales mais à
ce niveau-là bah l'Inde naturellement ça
fait longtemps que tu as pas été en et
il y a des proximités avec l'Occident
beaucoup plus marqué une communication
beaucoup plus fluide même avec les
présidents que ce soit Macron ou les
autres d'ailleurs européens qu'entre
queig jping et les les présidents
européens tu tu as déjà été en Inde non
je suis allé en Chine mais je ne suis
pas allé en Inde non non je suis pas
allé en Inde et mais sur le sujet de
l'adossement alors avec une monnaie
commune la création de la monnaie des
bricks devait être annoncé entre le 22
et le 24 août au sommet de Johannesburg
en Afrique du Sud 24 août dernier et
finalement il y a pas de grande annonce
par rapport à la la création d'une
monnaie c'est que le système des bricks
ne serait pas en mesure aujourd'hui
malgré la population qui représente 40 %
de la population mondiale non mais
d'imposer aux Américains un adossement
quelconque l'adossement alors en 1945
était imposé par les États-Unis mais
aujourd'hui en aucun cas les bricks
auraient la capacité d'imposer un
système de banque centrale semblable à
celui qu'on connaît avec un adossement
que ce soit à l'or ou à d'autres valeurs
je faisais la distinction précédemment
entre des matières premières bien que
l'or soit une matière première mais pas
un flux d'exportation mais une valeur
première un petit peu plus qu'une
matière première et je faisais la
distinction parce qu'ils l'ont annoncé
comm comme tel en disant un panier de de
devis et de matière première et un
adossement alors et avec ça on va créer
un adossement global pour notre nouvelle
monnaie mais en aucun cas les pays
occidentaux accepteront une nouvelle
monnaie qui représente plus qu'une
monnaie dans le système monétaire mais
la nouvelle monnaie de référence d'un
nouveau système oui je suis d'accord
mais je pense que la la plausibilité la
possibilité d'une pareil pareil
négociation si vous voulez est
infiniment petite je pense pas que les
États-Unis accepte ça ils ont encore une
grande prédominance financière et ils
sont en train de perdre leur
prédominance économique et ça les embête
et alors on brandit le drapeau drapeau
de la démocratie pour dire que on a
raison de bloquer la Chine mais mais en
la bloquant on crée aussi des problèmes
majeurs et ce que vous avez dit des
BRICS c'est très intéressant les bricks
sont en train de se détacher du système
américain euh qui était autrefois le
leur et ils sont en train de se
rapprocher de la Chine d'une manière
très importante
et on va voir ce que va donner le
système monétaire international la vraie
monnaie des bricks pour le moment c'est
Luan quoi qu'il en soit qui représente
si on regarde le classement des monnaies
de réserve en terme de réserve de change
le dollar c'est 60 % de réserve de
change au sein des banques centrales
l'euro 20 % et le Yan et après la le
sterling et le le le et la monnaie
japonaise à 2,8 et devrait monter à 5 %
d'ici à 2030 moi j'ai vu le
ministre compétent de la Chine il y a
quelques jour et je lui ai parlé de ces
questions et il m'a dit mais j'ai
absolument pas l'intention de
concurrencer le dollar mais parce que
l'avenir n'est pas au monie de réserve
le dollar il est ce qu'il est mais les
Chinois n'ont nullement l'intention de
faire du grand pas bagarer là-dessus
simplement je souhaiterais un système
plus équilibré vous savez que la Chine a
6 % des voies au Fond Monétaire
International alors que les États-Unis
on ont 16 % et évidemment il y a une
disproportion et normalement on calcule
les participations au fonds monétaires
sur la base de chiffres objectifs dans
lesquels il y a le PIB et
le la place dans le commerce
international et il est évident que la
Chine est sous-évaluée
donc a une manière intelligente de les
remettre dans le circuit ça dépend parce
que le Yan est déjà la première monnaie
de commerce transfrontalier depuis mars
2023 aujourd'hui le Yan est le la
première plus d'augmenter leur C part
absolument c'est ce que demandent les
chinois au FMI il détiennent je crois 4
% de code part au FMI et les Américains
question une question pour vous deux une
question pour vous deux euh vous croyez
à la stabilité de l'euro non absolument
pas donc première question vous monnaie
chère et pas monnaie forte l'euro faut y
croire faut pas y croire faut rester
positionné en euro ON NE donne PAS de
conseil d'investissement
mais l'euro qui se fait attaquer par une
inflation une dévaluation de on est à
combien de pourcent 8 10 12 15 % donc
chaque année on perd 15 % de notre
capacité de pouvoir d'achat l'euro vous
y croyez est-ce que va y avoir une
dislocation de l'euro de l'Europe de de
tout ce qui va avec en général en
général une monnaie nationale
est le symbole de l'économie et du pays
quand vous pensez aux États-Unis vous
pensez au-delar quand vous pensez à la
France vous pensez quand vous pensez à
l'Europe
euh je ne suis pas sûr que vous pensiez
à l'euro comme symbole de l'unité de
cette union je pense que vous pensez
plutôt à l'euro comme un une source de
débat une source de euh
de différence de de position entre le
Nord et le Sud de l'Europe enfin c'est
c'est moins une monnaie au
sens au sens embrassant du terme qui est
généralement utilisé et c'est plus euh
la manifestation de d'accord ou
désaccord sur la politique à suivre vous
naavez pas ça aux États-Unis le conseil
de la Fed il est il est ce qu'il est
mais il
amain peut pas tout à fait dire la même
chose de l'Europe donc ça c'est la
première observation la deuxième
observation c'est que l'Union Européenne
est une union de 27 États qui ont chacun
leur politique budgétaire et leur
politique fiscale et leur politique en
général et leur physionomie économique
également avec des petits pays
touristiques et des gros pays
industriels alors cette
hétérogénéité consubstantiel à l'euro se
traduit par une certaine diversité à
l'égard de ce qu'on pense devoir être
l'inflation et la monnaie la troisième
chose c'est que c'est
que le taux d'intérêt de l'euro est un
taux
moyen par définition puisquil est seul
et que les pays sont très dispersés et
très
hétérogènes résultat le taux d'intérêt
il est valable pour la moyenne mais il
est probablement trop bas pour les pays
les plus inflationnistes qui sont ceux
du Sud et peut-être trop haut pour les
pays du Nord qui sont les moins
inflationnistes donc vous avez
une
différenciation de la politique
monétaire par rapport à un ensemble qui
est extrêmement fragmenté et extrêmement
hétérogène ça rend la politique
monétaire très difficile
et je vais vous donner un
exemple si vous
calculez la
compétitivité de l'euro en
Allemagne en prenant tous les critères
de compétitivité relatif et comparatif
vous voyez que avec l'euro qui est-ce
qu'il est qui est une moyenne avec
l'euro les Allemands ont une monnaie
dans laquelle ils exportent qui
est inférieure à peu près à 10 à 15 %
par rapport à ce qu'elle serait si
c'était une monnaie
nationale
l'avantage commercial que donne cette
sous-évaluation d'un dechmark théorique
euh est énorme énorme une dévaluation de
15 % c'est énorme dans le le comparatif
de des échanges mondiaux dans dans un
monde ouvert
et et donc ça vous montre que la monnaie
euro est différente d'une monnaie
nationale lambda ça va se casser la
gueule ou ça va pas ça va se casser la
gueule ou ça va pas se casser la gueule
parce que faire une politique monétaire
à 27 où on est même pas capable de
s'entendre pour des masques sur du
tarmac non mais l'euro va chuter
considérablement l'euro l'euro il va il
va chuter il va chuter on est sur un bon
trit ça je ne veux pas répondre à çael
parce que je n'ai pas les éléments qui
me permettent de le dire
mais si vous avez un ensemble très
hétérogène du point de vue économique et
du point de vue inflationniste
euh c'est c'est problématique non mais
qui aurait dit il y a quelques temps
encore que l'Allemagne se retrouverait
dans la situation dans laquelle elle se
trouve aujourd
tu tu parles des analystes qui étaient
pas foutus de savoir que l'industrie
allemande était dépendante du gaz oui je
parle de ceux qui nous présentaient
l'Allemagne comme l'exemple à suivre
mais certainement par rapport à des
mesures venues du Saint-Esprit et pas
par rapport à la dépendance au gaz
effectivement c'est les mêes personnes
qui travaillent pour l'Allemagne mais
c'est les mêmes personne surtout qui
nous disent qu'on doit pas acheter du
gaz aux Russes parce qu'ils sont russes
et qu'ils commettent des massacres en
Ukraine ce que je ne cautionne pas
naturellement mais qu'on peut acheter ce
même gaz s'il a transité par l'Inde
parce qu'il faut savoir qu'il y a une
société qui s'appelle rosenft qui sur
laquelle le cremelin à la main qui s'est
procuré 56 tanquers en seulement 12 mois
l'année passée pour livrer du gaz et du
pétrole à l'Inde du du pétrole et du gaz
qui revient vers l'Union européenne donc
l'Union européenne entretemps a signé
des accords avec l'Azerbaïdjan puisqu'il
y a du gaz en Azerbaïdjan aujourd'hui je
crois qu'on cautionne pas vraiment le
conflit eurkarabak qu'est-ce qu'on fait
le le fait de parle plus en T les cas on
en parle plus beaucoup là mais le fait
de doubler les ce qui est prévu d'ici à
2027 les livres raison de gaz venu
d'Azerbaïdjan vers l'Union européenne on
arrête ça on abandonne parce que
l'Azerbaïdjan n'est pas sur la même
ligne diplomatique que nous que les pays
de l'UE ça c'est totalement abrant et
au-delà de ça il y a les les les le le
sujet du nucléaire qui est un grand
sujet dans les années 2000 la filière pr
était pour des raisons monétaires
également et personne n'en parle de cela
abandonné totalement pour faire une PR
il faut en réalité des dizaines de
milliards parce qu'il y a toujours des
retards on s'aperçoit que sur le béton
on n plus la même technique
qu'auparavant on est obligé de refaire
les les couvercles en béton en aluminium
également on a perdu la main ça coûte
une quinzaine de milliards pour livrer
une centrale donc la filière repè il y a
y a des problèmes climatiques également
qui font qu'on a pas les mêmes
certitudes qu'on avait auparavant par
rapport au au au circuit d'eau qui sont
nécessaires pour rafraîchir les les PR
et il y avait des technologies les
petits réacteurs modulaires dans les
années 2000 et début 2010 qui étit sous
étude et qui pouvait être implanté sur
des terrains de 1000 m² environ et qui
était beaucoup moins coûteux à implanter
c'est ces technologies beaucoup moins
coûteuse que les PR et nous avons
abandonné totalement ce ce ces
perspectives totalement pour se se
fourvoyer vers les énergies
renouvelables et uniquement les énergies
renouvelable ce qui était intéressant à
faire d'autre part en complément et ce
qui a totalement sabré les perspectives
d'industrialisation de la France alors
aujourd'hui on voit effectivement des
ministres des secrétaires d'État vous
dire il faut réindustrialiser et ce sont
les mêmes généralement qui vous disent
même à droite ce qui paraît totalement
aberrant on va essayer de de limiter les
super profits on va demander de réduire
les marges ou alors on va essayer de
faire augmenter les salaires
indirectement mais depuis quand vous ne
voulez pas qu'il y ait de profit dans
des économies libérales le problème ça
n'est pas le profit ça n'est pas le fait
qu'il y a des super profits le problème
c'est que vous avez des petites sociétés
aujourd'hui qui sont beaucoup plus taxé
que des grosses sociétés c'est ça le
gros problème si vous voulez faire si
vous voulez relancer l'économie libérale
en France aujourd'hui vous avez deux ou
trois mesures vous prenez toutes les
sociétés qui déclarent moins de 20
millions de chiffres d'affaires à
l'année en France vous allégez de 80 %
les prélèvements obligatoires dans
l'intervalle vous appliquez ce que
l'Union européenne prétendait faire il y
a déjà de nombreuses années mais ce qui
n'a en réalité jamais été appliqué c'est
prélèvement c'est les cotisations les
cotisations l'imposition c'est le le le
l'interdiction ou en tout cas une
limitation drastique de la
délocalisation et vous imposez à toutes
les sociétés lorsqu'elle livre
lorsqu'elle délivre un service sur le
territoire français à de la population
française du tertière c'est-à-dire des
téléconseiller des secrétaires de
salariés des Français donc vous avez
plus un seul téléconseiller qui est sur
une plateforme à 2000 km de de du
territoire et qui communique avec des
clients français et là à partir de là
vous récupérez les prélèvements que vous
avez perdu sur des sociétés à échelle
territorialestisation des cotisations et
sur sur ces sociétés sur ces emplois
donc vous créer un cercle vertueux qui
permet de relancer l'économie libérale
et c'est à partir de là que vous pouvez
stabiliser la valeur de la M alors juste
une question pour vous deux c'est
relancer l'économie
libérale moi je vais vous poser la
question c'est pour aller
où relancer l'économie de pour aller
vers ce que Emmanuel Macron appelit mais
d'une façon caricaturale le
ruissellement c'est-à-dire une
répartition tout simplement de la
richesse assez naturelle parce que le
grand sujet économique ou politique
au-delà de tous les débats c'est la
Répartition de la Richesse et personne
n'ose le dire et pourtant moi je peux
dire que je suis pas marxiste loin de là
des faux air quand même non absolument
pas absolument pas mais le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le système dans
lequel nous sommes ça n'est pas du
libéralisme c'est de la supercherie
c'est du communisme est-ce est-ce que
c'est un système administré de A à Z
c'est de la
socialondialisation c'est de la
socialondialisation ça veut dire que
vous avez une économie libérale qui est
parfaitement étouffée ce qui conduit
nécessairement à une prise de
responsabilité d'un État qui est forcé
de sortir le carnet de chèque et d'autre
part d'alimenter le carnet de chèque par
de l'endettement qui est payé par la
population elle-même ça veut dire que ça
n'est plus la population qui décide de
ses dépenses et qui se gère c'est l'État
qui décide des dépense mais à un tel
niveau qu'aujourd'hui vous avez un état
qui pendant quelques années vous dit on
va vous déduire d'impôts des certaines
rénovations et quelques années plus tard
qui vous dit bon on va augmenter la TVA
sur ces mêmes rénovations donc ça veut
dire que l'État décide tour à tour de
gagner de l'argent ou de vous en faire
économiser sur ce qu' considérit comme
étant un mal et juste après ce qu'
considère comme étant un bien bah ça ça
s'appelle de la dépossession et ça n'a
rien à voir avec du libéralisme le
principe du libéralisme c'est de laisser
au maximum la possibilité de créer de la
richesse et de ne pas figer la richesse
qui a été CR le marché il a pas l'air de
trop se réguler là non ah non le marché
se régule pas du tout mais le marché est
totalement paralysé aujourd'hui
Jacques ça sent le sapin ça sent le
sapin est-ce que ça sent le sapin
économiquement parlant est-ce qu'on est
sur des rails c'est le déclin est très
prononcé pendant des années on a
pénalisé les entreprises françaises avec
des charges excessives qui n'était pas
justifié et ces charges ont chargé la le
les comptes de ces entreprise d'une
manière telle qu'elles ne sont plus
compétitives et donc elles ont disparu
nous avons perdu presque la moitié de
notre industrie en 20 ans c'est et c'est
entièrement man made c'est fait par
l'homme c'est nous avons décidé ça et
nous avons décidé d'une manière
totalement non démocratique et par
l'excès des charges publiques nos
dépenses publiques sont près de 60 % du
produit intérieur brut alors que la
moyenne européenne est à 50 % et 10 % de
charg de plus pour une entreprise par
rapport au PIB c'est la différence entre
la vie et la mort et donc nous sommes
collectivement coupables dans un pays
qui se dit démocratique d'avoir
organisé la la perte de son industrie la
montée du chômage et le désarroi des
jeunes je trouve que c'est un bilan
effroyable voilà voilà
ma vérité qui qui est la même que celle
que que Tom a rappelé la deuxième chose
que je voulais dire qui est plus
technique c'est
que l'Union européenne monétaire ne
supprime pas la nationalité de la
balance des paiements il faut le savoir
ça on n pas une balance des paiements
européenes on a une balance des
paiements français qui est déficitaire
une balance des paiements allemande qui
excédentaire on a des situations
différentes
et la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
par rapport aux États-Unis qui ont 50
états il y a aussi des balances des
paiements déficitaires dans certains
états des balances de paiement
excédentaires dans d'autres comment se
fait l'ajustement aux
États-Unis il se fait d'une manière très
simple il se fait par le marché
financier essentiellement un peu par la
redistribution publique par les organes
fédéraux mais surtout par les marchés
c'est-à-dire que la fluidité des
capitaux aux États-Unis est telle que
des capitalistes qui se disent tiens au
Dakota ça marche pas maintenant mais il
y a une capacité de de gain si j'y
investis ça ça arrive et la
redistribution par le marché pas par
l'État par le marché et le phénomène
central regardez l'Europe l'Europe a
aussi des des équilibres de balance des
paiements dans son sein comment
sont-ils financés ils sont pas financés
par le marché financier européen
pourquoi parce qu'il y a pas de marché
financier européen on désire en créer un
tous les ministres qui se succèdent à
Bruxelles disent ah ça serait bien
d'avoir un marché financier européen
mais il n'existe pas et donc comment ça
se fait et ben ça se fait de la manière
suivante les déficits français italien
espagnol grec portugais Sam masse et les
excédents allemands
autrichiens néerlandais Sam masse et ça
fait des comptes qu'on appelle en jargon
les comptes target qui sont énormes et à
la différence des États-Unis où il y a
ces comptes mais ces comptes sont réglés
tous les ans et l'épaulement du marché
facilite beaucoup ce règlement chez nous
ils sont pas réglés alors ils s'ent
tassent et les targets c'est maintenant
des milliards et des milliards pour ne
pas dire des centaines de milliards je
crois qu'il y a 400 milliards dans un
pays comme
l'Italie 1000 milliards de plus dans un
pays créditeur comme l'Allemagne donc ce
sont des comptes qui sont d'un certain
point de vue menaçants mais et inertes
mais ils sont là et la réalité c'est que
la diversité et le non fonctionnement
d'un marché capitaliste caractérise le
fait que en Europe les déséquilibres ou
les asymétries dans les économies ne se
résolvent pas alors c'est très grave ça
du point de vue de la la question que
vous posiez sur l'avenir de l'euro moi
je souhaitaais que on ait en Europe une
politique plus claire qu'on est un
budget européen qu'on est euh un marché
financier européen vous savez que les
excédents de balance des paiements
européens ceux de l'Allemagne des
Pays-Bas en particulier s'exportent
s'exportent vers qui vers les États-Unis
parce que l'argent est mieux rémunéré
aux États-Unis au lieu de cette espèce
idioie qui consisteê toujours un point
d'intérêt inférieur aux États-Unis donc
l'argent va là où ça rémunère et il va
là où il y a des perspectives de
croissance chez nous il y a pas de très
bonne perspective de croissance parce
que on est très désuni on est très désu
oui ce qu'on fait de mieux c'est la
réglementation la chatch non l'excès de
réglementation et surtout on ne veut
pasettre les réalité l'excès de rgl
vous regardez les pays qui sont par
exemple les pays touristiques la le
Portugal la Grèce qui était dans une
situation catastrophique il a une
quinzaine d'années sont les pays qui ont
la plus forte croissance les plus fortes
croissances de l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui le Portugal a encore de la
croissance parce que il est sorti du
marché régulier de l'électricité oui
notamment alors là on parle de l'Espagne
en particulier on se moquait d'ailleurs
du pb de l'Espagne on comparer les
richesses de l'Espagne et de la Russie
alors que en réalité il fallait
s'apercevoir que il y a le pays IB par
habitant prend en considération
également on parle de la France par
exemple on était à la 13e place en 1989
on est 25e aujourd'hui en terme de payb
par habitant donc ça il faut le prendre
en compte et et il y a la la la capacité
on parlait de monnaie
précédemment vous regardez les échanges
globaux le dollar c'est 45 % selon les
chiffres de la de de Swift les données
de Swift du mois de juillet c'est 44 %
en dollars 24 % en euros
et 4 % en yuan et pourtant le yuan est
la première monnaie du commerce
transfrontalier comme on le disait
précédemment ça veut dire que le plus
gros marché au monde aujourd'hui c'est
pas le commerce c'est le marché
obligataire c'est le marché de la dette
donc vous pouvez être un pays riche
parce que vous avez une capacité
d'éponger du déficit comme le disait
Jacques et d'émettre des titres
obligataires qui sont achetés par la
suite mais pas parce que vous avez de la
valeur intrinsèque et un pays qui a une
capacité touristique et en même temps un
équilibre démocratique parce que Croatie
par exemple il y a 2 3 millions
d'habitants donc c'est un petit peu plus
facile à gérer que des pays qui en on 70
ou 80 c'est joli en plus c'est joli il y
a du tourisme ils ont intégré l'eurozone
d'ailleurs assez récemment je je crois
qu'ils s'en mordent les doigts ils ont
vu leur leurs chiffres se s'effondrait
assez rapidement et donc lorsque vous
avez des valeurs euh tangibles si je
puis dire concrète de ressources vous
avez beaucoup moins à vous en faire que
lorsque votre richesse repose sur
émission de dette qui ne pourra plus
être acheté durant les années à venir ça
marche aussi avec la plus grosse armée
du monde alors le budget de Défense des
États-Unis c'est encore aujourd'hui
entre 30 et 50 % du budget de défense
global mondial donc c'est colossal
précédemment je disais que je
soupçonnais les Américains je dirais pas
de mentir mais dans joliver les
quantités de réserves d'or qu'ils
avaient ou qu'ils ont toujours mais
entre nous je les ai toujours soupçonné
de de manifier un petit peu leur
puissance militaire je pense pas a que
la capacité militaire aujourd'hui avec
les la la numérisation de la de la
guerre également parce que comme on ne
fait plus de la finance comme on en
faisait précédemment à l'instar de cela
on fait plus la guerre comme on la
faisait précédemment Jacques dans les
dans les banque centrale ou à la Banque
de France est-ce qu'il y avait des gens
spécialisés dans les concepts de guerre
économique est-ce que Bernard etbert
vous a initié au au au au concept de
guerre économique est-ce que d'autres
maîtres apprançais français ont essayé
de mettre des garts au sein de la banque
centrale pour dire attention là notre
banque centrale va être attaqué par une
autre banque centrale parce que ça
arrange un gouvernement est-ce que
Robert guillaumo vous vous a parlé de
tout
ça il y avait un service des études
économiques qui était très large et très
très compréhensif très embrassant donc
il il est possible que l'aspect
militaire que tu évoques a été traité
mais je ne me souvenais pas que c'était
une spécialité de la Banque de France et
en ce qui concerne la Banque centrale
européenne euh je ne suis pas sûr que
ils aient développé beaucoup cet aspect
des choses C à vérifier ça mais
euh moi ce qui me frappe dans la
conversation que nous avons c'est
que nous
affichons du libéralisme que nous ne
pratiquons pas je vais vous donner un
exemple la chose qu'un banquier central
ne doit pas faire parce que ce n'est pas
dans son mandat c'est pas dans sa
mission le gouvernement et le Parlement
ne lui ont jamais demandé de le faire
c'est d'allouer les ressources entre les
différentes catégories de
citoyens devez pas faire ça quand vous
êtes un banquier central vous êtes un
banquier central vous devez vérifier que
votre monnaie se déprécie pas et qu'elle
reste stable que fait la Banque centrale
européenne
elle fixe les taux d'intérêt pendant 20
ans à zéro en terme
réel je parle des taux d'intérêt
directeur c'est-à-dire les taux
d'intérêt qu'elle qu'elle sur lequel la
primauté absolue qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire en terme de
sociologie ça veut dire que la banque
centrale a alloué la création monétaire
et la création de richesse de ce
fait préférentiellement à une catégorie
de citoyens qui sont les
débiteurs et les créanciers c'est-à-dire
les petits
épargnants tant pis pour eux ils ont
zéro et les débiteurs ont zéro à payer
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
outrageusement avantagé je ne dis pas
que c'est bien ou mal je dis que ce
n'est pas le rôle d'une banque centrale
que de dire je vais allouer ma création
monétaire à une catégorie de citoyens
que je juge préférable à l'autre ce
n'est pas son boulot et elle le fait le
résultat a été que les débiteurs ont
énormément emprinté et que on a eu des
bulles financières
majeures c'est c'est une allocation de
ressources qui est faite la vérité c'est
que les banquiers centraux devaient être
plus modestes et que la répartition
entre les créanciers et les débiteurs
elle doit être faite par le marché par
les offreurs de capitaux qui sont face
aux demandeurs de capitaux avec des taux
de rémunération qui sont ceux du marché
jacqu Christine Christine Lagarde pour
vous c'est une bonne ministre c'est
c'est Christine Lagarde c'est
quoi c'est la présidente de la Banque
centrale européenne mais quand elle dit
quand elle dit on va rembourser mais
vous vous sentez bien par mes propos que
je n'approuve pas cette politique je
trouve
que la politique monétaire ne doit pas
être le seul jeu en ville ne do pas
l'être elle doit être un je en ville
mais la politique budgétaire et fiscale
est majeure elle est plus importante à
certain égard
et la vérité malheureuse est que en
créant de l'argent à zéro et à tire la
Rigo on a faciliter la vie de ceux qui
créent les problèmes budgétaires qui
deviennent des problèmes de
compétitivité
sociétécom vous avez immobilisé de
l'argent c'est on marche sur la tête
donc quand vous me demandez comment ça
va comment ça irait mieux qu'est-ce
qu'il faudrait faire je dirais la
première chose c'est de se remettre sur
ses pieds c'est ça l'air idiot mais
c'est c'est la vérité faut faire tomber
des têtes pour se remettre sur ses pieds
hein est-ce qu'il faut faire tomber des
têtes il faut accepter les réalités moi
c'est pas ça qui m'intéresse ce qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'on fasse des choses
intelligentes et normal il faut regarder
les chiffres surtout et ça lui il s
connaî parce que il étudie les
entreprises et vous êtes bien d'accord
qu'on a pénalisé les entreprises par la
puissance publique vous prenez le cas de
St microélectronices par exemple
aujourd'hui ST Microelectronics
bénéficie de 2,9 milliards d'aide de
l'État pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a plus
de liquidité à l'intérieur donc c'est
l'État qui est
déjà qui est forcé d'injecter de
l'argent il a raison c'est c'est quand
même enfin on on est pas très nombreux à
dire ça je je te remercie de nous ouvrir
tes tes tes tes micros mais quand même
on a une puissance publique qui a
ruiné les entreprises françaises c'est
c'est un beau succès qui
a en en majorant la dette publique posé
des problèmes majeurs à nos petits
enfants parce que les petits enfants ils
sont en face de quoi d'une dette énorme
bon alors ils peuvent qu'est-ce qu'on
fait devant une dette énorme ou bien on
la répuie mais à ce moment-là on est
fermé des financements étrangers pendant
30 ans bon c'est pas une très bonne
solution ou bien on les paye et à ce
moment-là on a un transfert de
ressources qui vous tue ses petits
enfants ou alors on restructure la dette
péniblement donc on laisse à nos petits
enfants un tableau tragique on les a
sacrifié systématiquement sur les retra
sur surtout et sur l'enseignement sur
sur la formation professionnelle on a
tout faux tout sur la santé publique sur
et on est en train de ruiner l'avenir du
pays qu'est-ce que c'est l'avenir du
pays c'est nos petits enfants c'est pas
nous c'est c'est une folie tout ça le
logement social par exemple vous avez 70
% de la population qui est éligible au
logement social en France on est la 7e
puissance du monde et vous avez 70 %
selon les barêes HE c'est les barêes
qu'il faut modifier moi quand je ça on
dit mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'il
y ait plus de pauvres qu'on supprime les
pauvres non là n'est pas la question je
veux qu'on modifie les barêes et qu'on
considère pas qu'il faille pénaliser les
communes qui refusent de saccager leur
territoire en ne construisant pas
suffisamment de logement sociaux et et
qu'on modifie les BR pour qu'il n'y ait
plus 70 % de personnes éligibles mais
qui a surtout une capacité d'empr et une
capacité d'emploi au sein de la
population c'est là que se trouve le
problème je vous donne le je vous donne
le micro pour parler d'un sujet qui vous
passionne
ouais si vous avez envie d'échanger avec
nous Jacques tu veux parler de
quoi je voudrais je voudrais parler de
quelque chose qui qui est en liaison
avec ce que tu nous as dit tout à
l'heure et c'est le point
suivant nous
pensons que nous sommes les participants
d'une société rationnelle c'est-à-dire
que les gens qui sont élus doivent
coopérer pour le bien public nous
pensons ça mais nous n avons tort de
penser ça parce que comme nous l'avons
dit
depuis 2h avec Tom ce n'est pas ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé c'est que
les la puissance publique nous a
fourvoyé nous a trompé et a amené le Pay
amené le pays à son déclin la France
d'aujourd'hui a décliné par rapport à la
France il y a 20 ou 30 ans d'une manière
majeure donc c'est pas pas un succès
c'est un échec fondamental cet échec
fondamental nous ne le reconnaissons pas
comme un échec fondamental moi je le
reconnais vous vous le reconnaissez Tom
le reconnaît mais on est très peu
nombreux parce que on est dans la
théologie officielle c'est-à-dire que il
y a des gens qui ont été élus qui sont
dans les palais ministériels et qui
décident de la vérité alors que ils sont
souvent incompétent et toujours
intéressé par une chose qui est leur
réélection alors donc je me dis nous
approchons intellectuellement cette
société d'une manière absurde nous
croyons que les gens sont désireux du
bien public ils ne ils ne le sont pas
fondamentalement ils sont intéressés par
leur avenir politique c'est ça la vérité
alors
je autour de celle que tu as posé et
c'est celle de la
démocratie je vote tous les 5 ans pour
des gens qui se répètent leurs erreurs
dans les palais
ministériels est-ce que je vis pour
autant en démocratie c'est la question
que je me pose et qui est un peu celle
que tu m'as posé tout à l'heure alors
pour ça j'ai besoin d'une d'une fable
j'ai besoin d'une d'une histoire et
cette histoire c'est l'histoire de
Galilée Galilée était un savant qui
vivait en Italie au 16e siècle et il
avait étudié d'une manière méticuleuse
d'une manière je dirais
presque pragmatique la position des
astres avec des instruments très
imparfaits mais des raisonnements très
justes et il était arrivé à la
conclusion
que c'était la terre qui tournait autour
du soleil et pas le soleil qui tournait
autour de la terre c une découverte
majeure une découverte que qui a changé
le le monde l'observation prime toujours
sur la doctrine absolument alors
l'église qui régnait en maître à
l'époque dans les affaires politiques
n'acceptait pas cette découverte de est
parce que elle était contraire à la
Bible à la Genèse qui disait que Dieu
avait commencé par créer la terre et que
tous les Ases tournaient autour de la
Terre alors ils ont fait le procès de
Galilée non pas le procès des faits
parce que les faits ils étaient là mais
le procès de la doctrine ce que vous
dites est est faux parce que ça va à
l'encontre de la Bible alors pour avoir
la paix Galilée a fini par signer son
acte d' d'abjogation il a dit bon ben
j'abjure je je j'ai eu tort de dire ces
choseslà c'est pas vrai et il a signé
dans une église était à gène et il y
avait un copain de Galilée qui était à
côté de lui et en sortant Galilé lui a
dit et pour J JIRA ce qui veut dire en
italien et pourtant elle tourne la terre
donc il il ne croyait pas du tout dans
sa
renonciation alors je je prends cette
histoire pour notre
temps quand nous disons les choses
raisonnables sur le déclin de la France
que nous avons dit avec Tom et toi
qu'est-ce qu'on nous dit on nous dit
d'abord on on nous écoute pas ensuite on
nous nous dit c'est contraire à tout ce
que nous disons nous dans les palais
ministériels c'est contraire donc vous
avez tort ce qui veut dire qu'on est
revenu à une société du Moyen-Âge je
pèse mes mots à une société du moyen-âge
où c'est la doctrine qui prime
l'observation des faits moi je suis
encore je suis un homme âgé je suis un
homme dont la durée de vie est très
limitée
je suis un homme qui est très heureux
d'être avec toi et vos camarades parce
que on peut dire des choses vraies on
peut dire des choses qu'on pense mais je
ne peux les dire que là j'écris des
livres on peut encore écrire en France
des livres mais il est très difficile
d'atteindre la presse parce que la
presse est dans la main du gouvernement
à beaucoup d'égards et il est très
difficile d'accéder à la radio et à la
télévision sauf pour des interview de 3
minutes dans lesquelles on na même pas
le temps de se présenter c'est fini euh
donc je je pense que nous sommes dans
une société qui est arriérée qui est
doctrinaire qui a abandonné les
principes de Pasteur Claude Bernard de
de
Descartes qui consistait à observer à
douter la première chose c'est de douter
c'est de dire le ministre Aby m'a
raconté ça mais je je doute il faut que
je doute l'autre jour j'étais à ber je
vais vous donner une histoire et par
parla du budget et je disais je
comprends pas votre budget vous répte
vous répétez tout le temps les mêmes
choses vous vous relancez les vieilles
strades de dépenses publiqu qu'on a dont
on n pas du tout sûr qu'elles ont la
moindre utilité ah ils m'ont dit non on
est obligé c'est les dépenses beauté je
dis c'est quoi ça il m'a dit bah c'est
les dépenses qu'on a déjà voté dans les
années précédentes alors on les
reconduit puisquelles ont été votées je
dis c'est précisément celle-là que vous
devez mettre en cause c'est les pas
c'est les anciennes vous les reportez
avec un sens de
religion mais c'est c'est c'est absurde
ouvrez les fenêtres regarder la réalité
alors donc on est dans une société et
sécurité c'est ça
doctrina et je n'aime pas les sociétés
doctrinaires parce que c'est des
sociétés qui engendre les fausses
informations qui engendrent la le déclin
la ce qu'on appelle vous savez quand on
raconte des trucs formidables dans la
presse et que c'est pas vrai fake new
oui enfin qu on faisait ça je me
souviens quand j'étais enfant ça c'est
un vrai souvenir qui peut intéresser aux
auditeurs j'avais 10 ans en 39 quand la
guerre a été déclarée et vous Savit que
en 39 il s'est rien passé et qu'en 40 on
a été envahi par les Allemands en
quelques semaines le pays était dévasté
et et qu'est-ce que j'entendais à l'âge
de 10 ans à la radio il y avait pas de
télé il y avait des radio ma mère
tournait toujours les boutons on
essayait d'avoir les informations on
entendait de la propagande c'était ce
que le terme que je cherchais on disait
l'armée française est remarquable nous
avons déjoué la position
allemande je sais pas quoi c'était
entièrement faux les Allemands
avançaient à une vitesse folle vers
Paris puis puis le sud de la France et
tout jeune que j'étais j'avais 10 ans
mais à 10 ans on n'est pas idiot à 10
ans je me disais mais on nous raconte
des blagues
les Allemands arrivent à toute vitesse
et on nous dit que tout va bien sur le
front donc j'avais àquis cette espèce
d'horreur de la propagande je je
détestais ça je disais à ma mère qui
était une femme intelligente une femme
très capable je lui disais mais mais
c'est fou ce qu'on nous raconte elle me
disait oui c'est fou et c'est faux et
alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est les
circonstances sont très différentes on n
pas l'armée all che nous
mais mais on a la même attitude on est
on est les premiers on est fort c'est
bien alors que on n pas les premiers on
n pas fort on devrait se réformer et
donc je suis je suis malheureux voilà on
vaer boire un whisky après d'accord on
ira boire un whisky pour
seter Tom est-ce que tu veux nous parler
d'un truc oui par rapport la G société
c'est que quoi qu'il advienne on sera
forcé de gérer la société il y a
forcément un modèle à choisir ou en tout
cas un conglomérat de modèle alors ça
peut être le libéralisme ça peut être la
main invisible ça peut être la
démocratie très directe ou indirecte et
ça peut être l'aristocratie également
mais la pire des choses est un régime
aristocratique avec des aristocrates de
mauvaise qualité vous n'avez rien de
pire qu'une aristocratie de mauvaise
qualité parce qu'à ce moment-là vous
avez le masque de la démocratie le
masque de la démagogie mais vous n'avez
aucun unee représentation ni populaire
ni élitiste et ça c'est le gros problème
dans lequel on se trouve aujourd'hui je
dirais même que moi j'avais été très
marqué dans mes jeunes années par un
livre d'Arthur schopenhower qui
s'appelait le monde comme volonté et
comme représentation essae de l'art
d'avoir toujours raison c'est pas mal et
l'art d'avoir toujours raison qui a un
petit livre mais très intéressant
également le monde comme volonté comme
représentation que chopenhower avait
écrit en 1818 il était âgé de 27 ou 28
ans à cette à cette époque- làà et il
définissait bien longtemps avant que
Nietzsche en face la ressussait pour
ainsi dire un petit peu plus
euh mystifié avec la volonté de de
puissance il définissait le concept de
volonté le vouloir vivre derviller
c'est-à-dire cette volonté aveugle qui
anime disait-il tout ce qu'il a vie donc
c'est presque un pléonasme la le vouloir
vivre la volonté de vivre la volonté
d'exister face à l'existence en ayant
pour seul bien l'existence
et shopenhower était particulièrement
influencé par les philosophies
hindouistes et bouddhistes et à la fin
de sa vie dans un ouvrage magnifique qui
s'appelle les pararga et paralipoméa et
principalement le dernier chapitre les
aphorismes sur la sagesse dans la vie il
en arrive à une conclusion que j'avais
du mal à comprendre dans mes jeunes
années qui était le fait de devoir se
libérer de la volonté pour pouvoir
atteindre la plénitude et je crois que
malheureusement cette espèce qui est la
mienne aujourd'hui l'espèce humaine est
en train de se libérer de la volonté
elle se libère de la volonté en
anéantissant tout ce qui permet
l'évolution vous n'avez jamais eu autant
d'obésité qu'aujourd'hui vous n'avez
jamais eu autant de dépendance
qu'aujourd'hui et pour autant jamais
autant de dépenses médicales et jamais
autant de capacité à entretenir le corps
humain si je puis dire ça veut dire que
j'avais écrit un livre dans mes jeunes
années qui s'appelait instinct mimétique
et solitude à servi dans j'avais 14 ans
pas loin mais et mais je l'avais modifié
qui est très ble d'ailleurs qui avait eu
son petit succès à ce momentlà qui est
très accessible et je définissais mais
d'autres l'avaient fait d'une façon plus
politique Marx notamment d'ailleurs
l'homme que l'on est l'être humain la
femme ou l'homme en société et à l'état
naturel et vous pouvez devenir un
architecte un avocat un esséiste un
philosophe un économiste ou un maçon
mais vous ne devenez pas une femme vous
devenez pas vous ne devenez pas un
surhumain malheureusement aujourd'hui
mais je veux dire vous ne devenez
pas quelque chose d'autre nêtre autre
que celui que vous êtes au départ et la
principale démission lorsque l'on est un
acteur politique c'est-à-dire lorsqu'on
dirige un état et lorsqu'on donne la
musicalité citoyenne de cet état c'est
de permettre de délivrer à la population
d'entretenir convenablement son
enveloppe humaine son enveloppe
corporelle et ça ça n'est plus du tout
le cas aujourd'hui au même titre que les
banques centrales ne savent plus
garantir la monnaie ce qui était leur
mission les gouvernements aujourd'hui ne
savent plus garantir le progrès et le
bien vivre en société donc moi aussi je
suis très inquiet par rapport à la
situation politique et sociétale pour
autant le le conseil en quelque sorte
que je peux donner aux jeunes de ma
génération c'est de continuer j'ai pas
posé la question encore enfin oui oui je
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ce travail
non non je TR livres avant ah ben très
bien ouais TR livres je poursuis sur TR
livres et après un conseil pour les
jeunes générations diplomatie d' Ricky
Singer qui est passionnant et
prémonitoire alors si
si si tu conseilles ça je conseille
aussi les mémoires de de Hoover ouais
ououais de la CIA
et alors plus récent et d'un
contemporain que j'ai reçu dans mon
émission et qui est un être brillant
c'est Hubert Vedrine c'est le
Dictionnaire amoureux de la géopolitique
qui se lit est très sympa il est très
sympathique absolument il est très
sympathique très cultivé ça se lit pas
comme un dictionnaire amoureux parce que
lui-même le dit il n'est pas amoureux de
la géopolitique mais passionné pour
ainsi dire acteur spectateur de la
géopolitique il y a des références très
que l'on peut lire avec beaucoup de
fluidité à la aux années 60 70 80 qui
l'a connu et à la situation politique et
géopolitique actuelle donc ça c'est un
c'est un très bon ouvrage que je
recommande à tous toutes celles et ceux
qui s'intéressent à l'économie à la
géopolitique et le trisème je citerai
pas celui de Jacques de la rosère mais
si si si on a droit je peux bien s P
citer qui est un livre absolument
magistral dire en toute sincérité le le
la fin de l'illusion oui c'est ça mettre
fin à l'illusion financière voilà parce
qu'il y a un sous-titre et qui se lit on
s'en délecte j'ai lu C édité chez odudil
Jacob et j'ai invité Jacques que je
connais depuis seulement 6 mois
d'ailleurs dans mon émission à la suite
de la lecture de ce livre que Maria et
Oliviera que je salue m'avait fait
parvenir son éditrice j'ai trouvé ce
livre absolument magistral c'est la
définition la plus efficiente la plus pr
de la situation économique et financière
même si les ravages de la finance sont
soulignés c'est une définition de la
situation financière actuelle un conseil
pour les jeunes générations Tom parce
que toi
1995 c'est toi le plus jeune de non toi
tu es toi tu
es jusqu'à présent c'était toujours moi
donc là c'est toujours toi encore c'est
toi le plus jeune c'est toi qui va être
du moin ta génération qui va être obligé
de réparer tous les pot cassés donc
est-ce que tu as un conseil pour cette
génération sacrifié par des vieux
boomers qui ne veulent pas lâcher
système défendez bec et ongle vous qui
êtes de ma génération le sens de la
propriété gagnez sans faille et ne vous
laissz jamais influencer par les mythes
et les théories déclinistes de l'époque
ne vous laissez jamais assister aimez
l'argent aimer le profit aimer les
femmes aimer la force continuer et le
respect je te demanderai ton conseil
mais je je citerai pas le respect non je
citerai pas le respect je mais je suis
obligé d'épiloguer à ce propos par
rapport au respect je euh je pense que
la meilleure façon de respecter est
celle qui consiste à respecter par
hasard c'est-à-dire par occasion il ne
faut pas chercher à être bienveillant il
faut faire acte de bienveillance lorsque
l'occasion se
présente pas de faire beaucoup de Cop
toi ah ou j'en ai beaucoup euh euh
Jacques trois livres à conseiller à la
communauté alors
euh un un des livres que je recommande
il s'appelle appelle la malédiction
d'Icar alors je simplifie ICAR est un
personnage MTH mythologique qui était le
fils d'un architecte s'appelait ddal et
il avait
construit une sorte d'avion personnel
avec des plumes qui étaient attachées
les unes aux autres avec de la cire et
son père lui a dit c'est bien tu arrives
à voler avec cet appareil mais ne
t'approche pas trop du soleil parce que
le soleil est chaud et il va te fondre
les la cire de tes ailes mais ICAR a cru
qu'il
pouvait dépasser les conseils de son
père
et il s'est mis à voler ça se passait
bien il est monté il s'est rapproché du
soleil le soleil a fait fondre les les
plumes ikarrê tombé et la Chute d'Icar
est un phénomène qui est né de
l'excessive orgueil de l'excessive
confiance et tout ce que nous avons dit
pendant 2h c'est l'excessive conscience
qu' ces types qui sont dans les palais
ministériels et qui en réalité nont rien
à y faire et et qui s'imaginent qu'
peuvent s'approcher du soleil ça c'est
le premier bouquin le deème
bouquin c'est un livre d'un un
ex-ambassadeur qui s'appelle nous étions
bien seuls c'est un livre remarquable
parce que c'est le livre qui décrit les
conséquences du traité de varsaill et
tout le monde croit qu'on a fait une
erreur une énorme erreur à Versailles en
pénalisant l'Allemagne de telle façon
qu'elle allait avoir l'inflation les
problèmes sociaux puis Hitler la réalité
est toute différente l'Allemagne n'a pas
été touchée par la guerre de 14 il y a
pas eu de bombardement il y a rien eu
c'est la France qui a été touchée et
Kees a réussi à bâtir une mythologie
selon laquelle les pénalités que la
France avec clémenenceau a imposé à
l'Allemagne au traité de Versailles ont
été à
l'origine des des drames européens
Gard il n'en est rien et l'auteur le
démonre Gérard har l'auteur Gérard et le
trè livassadeur de France au
étsis un ancien ambassadeur qui voit
juste pas tout le temps enfin bon sur
dans ce bouquin là c'est il y a les
faits il y a les chiffres il y a tout et
le trè livre va vous surprendre c'est le
livre qui vient d'être consacré Bruno
lere non
non d'igade je ne sais pas si vous savez
qui est André darigade c'était un
coureur cycliste et c'était le coureur
qui était toujours numéro de parce que
son objectif c'était de favoriser
l'équipe de France les les Bobet les
antil les grands cette période alors il
était toujours numéro 2 mais une fois
dans sa vie il a gagné le Tour du Monde
pas le Tour de France le tour du monde
qui se donnait en Italie et il l'a gagné
contre un coureur prestigieux qui était
copi donc une fois le numéro 2 éternel
qui était un très brave type qui pensait
que à son équipe jamais à lui une fois
il a été gagnant et et et champion du
monde alors c'est une petite biographie
qui est sans histoire d'un professeur de
lettres à la Sorbonne qui s'appelle Baon
Baudon je crois et qui est très bien
fait voilà mes trois livres ton dernier
bouquin il s'appelle comment comment ton
dernier livre il s'appelle comment il
s'appelle la vie d'André
darigade et ton dernier livre Le le
vôtre le vôtre ton dernier
livre c'est s'appelle mettre fin à
l'illusion
financière le fait que nous vivons tous
sur un nuage un nuage qui qui ne veut
rien dire tout le monde travaille
écoutez c'est quand même scandaleux tout
le monde travaille pour 10% de la
population qui fait de la la spéculation
c'est c'est c'est pas une blague mais il
faut les rencontrer les 10 % pour voir
l'état l'état alors ça c'est mon bouquin
à moi ça est-ce que tu as un conseil
pour les jeunes générations une
bouteille à la mer oui oui oui j'ai un
conseil fondamental d'abord ne vous
laissez pas
endoctriner
pensez avec votre tête vous êtes pas
plus bê que les autres pensez essayez de
voir qu'est-ce qui est juste qu'est-ce
qui est pas juste
ça c'est le conseil essentiel la trè
chose prenez goût à la vie faites
l'amour soyez soyez des jeunes heureux
parce que c'est ça la vie c'est c'est
pas endoctriné par des types dans des
palais ministériels voilà c'est les
trois conseils Jacques Tom merci merci à
toi merci à
toi
[Musique]